Greetings, fellow travelers.
It is I, Rich Roll, once again, after a brief respite,
the nature of which will soon be clear,
here in brotherhood, with my podcast husband,
Mr. Adam Skolnick, master of pen, scroll and word.
Here to pontificate, to traverse a diversity of terrain,
both high-minded and perhaps frivolous.
For those new to the roll-on edition of the podcast,
this is all about stories, big and small,
what catches our attention,
what deserves a brighter spotlight.
We typically buttress that with a bit of show and tell.
We share a few wins of the week and we round it all out
by answering some of the questions dropped
on our voicemail, which you can ring up
at 4-2-4-2-3-5-4-6-2-6.
What is going on, my man?
Just sitting here contemplating
the magnificent interdependence of all things.
Well, that should be chalked up as frivolous.
Oh, it's supposed to be frivolous?
Yeah.
The way I approach it is very frivolous though.
I approach it like--
On the surface level?
Yeah, like, all the people that can
end up working towards giving me my snacks.
Listen, a little existential angst
is good fuel for the fire.
But I don't think it's angst, you know,
maybe it's fatherhood or maybe it's insomnia.
But I have been focused on the great mesh of society
and how so many people play their role,
and in so doing, you know,
society works and it's kind of phrased sometimes,
and there's like little holes that we have to patch up.
But for the most part, we are so interdependent
we don't even think about it.
We don't really take time to think about
how much others do for us and we do for others,
just by playing our role.
I think it's a beautiful thing.
Did you do DMT over the weekend?
I wish, I wish.
We are but cogs in the wheel of a matrix
that although perhaps flawed at times does cohere.
It coheres.
It feels coherent at most of the time, even...
We're tiny little cells in the microbiome
of a greater ecosystem.
We play our small little part
with being blindly unaware of the greater mechanisms
at play.
Right, and occasionally things fail.
Like when the sewage system of Los Angeles failed
for like seven hours and 17 million gallons
of raw sewage spilled out around DockWeiler Beach
in the Santa Monica bay.
It fails sometimes, that is not a criticism
of the good people of the sewage treatment plant.
It just happened that it was a failure.
Shit goes sideways.
Literally shit went sideways
It is weird how,
here, everybody knows
that for a period of, I dunno, you might know better,
how many days after there's a rainstorm
that you just don't go in the ocean
and we all have just normalized that,
like, okay, you don't go in.
And then at some point we decide,
I guess it's okay to go back in.
Right, well now, there is a way to figure it out.
You can go on the LA county website,
but after this, they were really taking a lot of tests.
And so now everything is good except for like one beach.
So we're back in.
I got back in on Saturday,
I was like a week out of the water.
Got the gills wet again.
It was fun, but everything's good.
We have a family of red tailed hawks
in the yard, that live in our yard,
which is pretty cool.
That's cool.
You've moved into a new abode.
We moved into the hawk's nest.
I guess that's what I'm gonna name it maybe.
That's cool.
On that subject of being cells in a greater
Yes.
Macro organism.
That really gets hammered home
when you are in a plane and you're descending
into Los Angeles and you just see the grid.
I agree.
It just goes forever.
And all the cars on the freeway that are like blood cells,
delivering oxygen to the various organs
so that it can all work as a greater system.
And it makes you think on some level,
we are just unconsciously participating
in some grander play,
where we play this tiny little role
that allows the whole thing to function.
And it's a trip, man.
It is a trip.
We're all the stars of our own great grand opera
that no one else is watching.
(laughs)
How do you know?
Somebody very well maybe watching.
Maybe, but also the honeycomb that is New York,
kind of the same thing.
You go, you drop in,
that's when you can feel small in the city.
You know, often for me,
I like to get out into nature to feel the reductionist.
But that's some of the beautiful things about New York.
One of the many things that's so exciting about New York
is that you feel so small in this amazing,
like hive of activity.
I feel very at home there and I feel very alive.
And also, I don't necessarily feel small.
I feel much more plugged in than I do here in Los Angeles.
So on the metaphor of the hive and the bee,
am I taking pollen from Los Angeles
and pollinating New York?
Or is it vice versa?
I don't know.
There's some sort of cross pollination happening.
You're cross pollinating friend.
Yeah, but I did spend nine days in New York,
which is why we had to take a bit of a respite
from roll-on, because I was out of town.
It's my first trip back there since before the pandemic,
I think I visited shortly before everything locked down
and it was freaking awesome to be there.
I just get such an energy boost from being in the city.
Despite what people may be hearing about law and order
and about everything being shut down
and it being a city, monopolized by fear.
My experience was very different.
I mean, I was in lower Manhattan.
You know, if you go to Midtown,
there's a lot of stuff that's shut down
and who knows what's going on in all those office buildings.
But Downtown, there's just so much young energy,
like everybody's out on the street.
And all the cafes have created these outdoor dining
situations that, by all accounts,
look like they're gonna be permanent,
which has made a lot of the streets,
much more walkable and much more bikeable.
A lot of the streets on the lower east side
are actually cordoned off to traffic.
Is that where you were, the lower east?
Yeah, I stayed on the lower east side.
I had a bike that I could ride around,
which was awesome.
And it was so much fun.
And what's great about New York is all the synchronicities
that you put yourself in a position to experience.
And my history with New York is that,
there is no other place on earth where that happens
with such frequency.
So people know Davey Greenberg
who shoots photographs for us.
I ran into Davy's brother who I'd never met.
I just knew what he looked like from Davey's Instagram.
Oh really?
You didn't plan that?
No, I just saw him and I was like,
hey Nile, you know, what's up.
And then I ran into Davey's girlfriend,
who was like staying in the same hotel as me.
I mean, it was wild.
It's just so fun to be in the flow of life there.
Everything is so accessible.
Everything's five to 10 minutes away
and you can get so much done.
I just felt this resurgence of life,
I felt like myself again, which was really cool.
Where does Rich Roll stay in New York City?
I stayed at the public hotel.
I'd never stayed there before,
but it's pretty centrally located like right in the Bowery.
Cool.
It's pretty great.
The reason for that trip was multi-fold.
I mean, it came about because Daniel,
whom agreed to be on the podcast, that episode just went up.
I got to dine at his extraordinary 11 Madison Park
and followed up the next day, by doing the podcast with him.
He was so delightful.
And what an extraordinary privileged experience it was
to enjoy his crazy cuisine.
I mean, it was amazing.
Not to, you know, repeat yourself on this podcast.
Do you get into all the dishes and that podcast?
'Cause I haven't listened to it yet.
No.
So give us some highlights, give us the highlights.
I can't remember the names of all of them,
they're so exotic.
But basically, he converted this restaurant
into a 100% plant-based menu.
And these experiences are like five hours long.
Like you go into the restaurant, they greet you by name.
Like they curate this unbelievably personal experience
where you feel really special.
And then they just start bringing dishes out
and the servers know all the backstory on everything
and they can explain to you
how these things are made.
And it's all very elaborate and very unique.
Like not just what you might expect with a plant-based menu,
but stuff that's like very outside of, you know,
very surprising in many ways.
All the dishes are pretty small,
but they bring so many that by the time you're done
you're sated.
Right.
But you're not feeling...
Typically, if you go to like a super fancy restaurant,
particularly that's of French influence, for example,
the dishes tend to be really rich
and you just feel very heavy
and it's very meat laden.
But here, you felt content,
but also energetic, which was cool.
They take everybody into the kitchen at one point,
to give you this tour.
It's immaculate that kitchen
I know, it's crazy.
I was like, how do you keep this place so clean?
With this huge portrait of Miles Davis in there,
and like some words of creative inspiration
and there's so many people working back there.
It's this unbelievable machine,
where Daniel has to be head chef, but also host.
He has to share personal moments with every patron.
It's quite a few hats that he has to wear.
But it's a machine that's like super well-oiled
and was pretty amazing.
That's incredible.
You went with Jeff Gordon, right?
Yeah, exactly.
Did he hook up that taste as you call him
as soon as you to try to get in?
Well, what happened was, when the news broke,
and I've told this story before,
so I don't wanna belabor it
but, when the news broke that he was gonna be reopening
the restaurant with a plant-based menu,
the food world like exploded.
Like I thought, oh, that's cool.
I didn't realize the magnitude of that announcement,
but the whole food world kind of lost their mind.
Yeah.
And Jeff texted me and he's like,
"You got to get on this right away."
And I was like, "Well, hook me up, that's cool."
Like, let's do it.
He connected the dots, Daniel got right back to me
and we kind of went from there.
That's cool.
So yeah, it was great.
That's what anchored the trip.
But I also was able to sit down with Eric Adams,
who is most assuredly going to be New York City's
next mayor.
He had just clenched the democratic nomination
for the mayoral candidacy,
but New York City is 70% Democrat.
So it's essentially a foregone conclusion
that he's gonna clinch it in November.
And what's interesting about him is that
he's been on my radar for many years.
I've gone back and forth with one of his chiefs of staff,
as Brooklyn borough president, over the years
about getting him on.
And for whatever reason, we just didn't sync up schedules,
et cetera.
And I've learned to trust,
like I just trust the timing of these things
that they're supposed to happen
when they're meant to happen.
And it was so cool to do it right after him
clinching this democratic mayoral position,
which makes it more compelling than had I done it
like two years ago,
because he is gonna be the mayor.
Throughout the campaign, it's really been
a law and order campaign.
It's all about police, policing, police reform.
There's been an uptick in violence and gun violence
in New York City.
Is it safe?
How are we going to make it safe?
Et cetera.
And what's been lost in that discussion is this insane
health story, health history that Eric Adams has.
Which is a big part of his advocacy.
Well he's an ex cop, right?
He's an ex cop.
He was a police officer for many years,
resigned as a captain and within the police department
was a reformer at a period when
it wasn't necessarily cool or safe to be a reformer,
you know, being a black police officer.
And he was able to make a certain amount of changes
within that construct.
Then he went into politics.
And of course that's why much of the debating
and punditry around this campaign
has been about police reform
and you know, the police
and what that looks like in New York City going forward.
But what's been lost
is this story of personal health.
Because he, I think it was about five or six years ago,
was diagnosed with type two diabetes.
When he went into the doctor,
it was very advanced, like I think stage four.
He went into the doctor because he was losing his eyesight.
He couldn't read his alarm clock.
Like he could barely see.
And he had numbness in his extremities,
in his feet and in his hands.
And he went to the doctor and the doctor was like,
you're way down the line on type two here.
You gotta go on all these meds.
You're probably going to lose your sight
within the next year, year and a half.
If you don't get on top of this,
we're gonna have to look at amputation.
Like that's what happens when type two gets out of control.
Something inside of him, it just didn't sit right
that he was suddenly gonna go on this panel
of medications for the rest of his life
and that there was nothing he could do about it.
And he went home and he googled reversing type two diabetes.
And he doesn't know why he used the word reversing
as opposed to treating or managing, but he did.
And that resulted in all this information about
Dr. Caldwell Esselstyn, Dr. Neal Bernard,
people who have been on this podcast,
who have been talking about the benefits of a plant-based
diet to treat and reverse some of these chronic
lifestyle illnesses, including type two diabetes.
He went to Cleveland, he met with Dr. Esselstyn,
he met with Dr. Bernard and he adopted a whole
full plant-based diet.
And within a couple of months, he'd reversed
all of his symptomatology
Amazing.
And his blood markers came down,
his A1C went from way out of control to below normal.
And he became this, not just convert,
but champion of this lifestyle.
And he started to advocate for changes in nutritional
policy, in Brooklyn,
with the hospitals and with the public schools.
And that's a big part of his platform,
should he become mayor.
Interesting, I didn't even know about any of that.
And I only had an hour with him,
so the conversation focuses on that,
but he's very charismatic as you might suspect.
And he's the sort of, you know,
latest iteration in a long line of charismatic characters
who become New York City mayors.
But in the context of the race, he's the centrist, right?
He was on the right side like that.
He's not about defunding the police.
He understands the police department needs reform,
but he is very much a Democrat,
but he's a law and order Democrat.
He's more in the Biden mold.
Yeah, he's up the middle.
So that was cool. I got to meet with the folks at 10,000,
we had a big design meeting.
We're cooking up some cool stuff,
but I can't get into specifics about now,
but we're gonna be doing some really fun stuff
in late fall, and I'll have more information about that.
But it was the first time that I had met the whole team
in person.
That was cool.
I got invited to go to the observation deck of this new
skyscraper called One Vanderbilt,
which is still under construction.
Parts of it are still under construction.
That's a brilliant business move
to open a commercial office building now.
(laughs)
Yeah, well this is such a gargantuan building,
it's been going on for years.
It's been years and years and years in the making.
But interesting you say that because actually
all of the commercial space in this building is occupied,
or leased, because, and I asked the question to, you know,
the guy who invited me up and he said,
that they will always be for premium office space.
It will always, you know,
his sense was that, it will always be filled.
It's the lower, and mid-level kind of commercial space
in New York City that's gonna be problematic.
But this building is built right next
to Grand Central Station.
And there's a tunnel underground
where you can go right from the train to the building.
So it makes it very convenient for high rollers
who live in Connecticut or Long Island
to come in and work and still expeditiously, like get home.
But this building is 96 floors high,
right in Midtown.
Right.
You know, Manhattan is essentially, you know,
we think of it as flat,
but right where Grand Central is, is like a hill.
I think it's the highest point on the island.
Bunker hill?
Is it Bunker hill?
I don't know.
I don't think that's
in New York City.
That's Boston, right?
Yeah, that's Boston.
You got your revolutionary war, geography off.
McGraw's hill, no such thing.
But they're building this incredible
kind of tourist attraction that involves
a glass elevator that goes on the outside
of the building with a glass floor on it.
Which was not operational the day that I was there,
but I was able to get up to the observation deck
on that 96 floor.
You go outside and you have this 360 degree experience
of seeing all of Manhattan from the perspective of Midtown.
And you look right at the empire state building,
and you're essentially at eye level with their observation
deck, which is insane.
And they're creating all of these, you know,
kind of extravagant experiences for tourists.
So that was cool to go up there.
Cause it was still under construction
and it's like a hardhat tour to be up there.
I saw that you, you peaked, Casey Neistat
commented on your observation deck photo.
Always a coup if Casey likes your photo,
I suppose, right?
Yeah, he was all excited.
Yeah, the flip-flops up against the glass.
Yes.
With the view.
The California bruh.
Yeah, exactly.
In New York.
Oh, another random synchronicity.
I've been going back and forth with Chris Chavez,
who listeners or viewers will remember
from Adam and I talking about the influencer Mile,
where Chris challenged Malcolm Gladwell to a mile
and then Malcolm put him in the grave.
And we'd gone back and forth about trying to connect.
But I got really busy and this is what tends to happen
when I go to the city.
Like I've learned to not over-schedule
and still my time gets totally occupied.
So I've all these people that I'd love to hang out with.
I was gonna go running with Hella.
I was gonna go running with Lindsay Crouse, and Mary Cain.
And like, none of that happened.
'Cause I was just pillar to post, filled up.
But I remember thinking like,
well, maybe I won't see Chris this time
but maybe I'll run into him.
And I was riding my bike through Greenwich village
and then I just spotted him jogging down the street,
which was cool.
And I yelled his name out.
He had earbuds in, he didn't hear me.
And I was like, well maybe that's not Chris.
And I whipped around, caught up to him
and just waited until he looked at me.
And then we had a little moment, that was special.
That is cool.
You were the first person
that I texted that photo to.
I told him I was like, Adam's gonna be so happy
that I ran into Chris Chaves.
That's awesome.
So that was cool.
And I love that about New York, that was so fun.
It's simple things like that,
that just, you know, made me so happy.
Big city, a small town.
So obviously we're gonna get into one of the movies
that you saw out there and then you had the big dinner.
Was that basically that it for your nightlife
or were you out at night too?
Were you all day and night?
'Cause when I'm in New York, I leave the room, whenever,
and then you're not back until...
You don't go back to the room.
You know, because I was doing podcasts
and having meetings and stuff like that,
I have to keep my energy high.
So I'm no longer, although there was a time
where it was all about staying out all night in New York.
That is not my relationship with the city anymore.
No, I figured that.
I was out late when I had dinner at 11 Madison Park,
because, I think the reservation was like seven 30
and I don't think I got home until like midnight.
I saw the Bourdain doc
which we're gonna talk about with Jeff Gordinier,
who invited me to see that.
Oh really?
So I was kinda late for that.
But other than that, I was back in my hotel room
at nine and I would just, you know,
basically watch the Tour de France and fall asleep.
Fantastic.
Yeah.
Good shit.
What else can I share about that?
I think that's it.
I mean, great trip.
I love New York City so much.
I really want
Do you ever think about...
Wanna spend more time there.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'd love to be more bi-coastal.
I get so done in a single day compared to Los Angeles.
Is that right?
You can have like four or five meetings
and still be cool.
In LA, you can have like one meeting a day
and it takes up your whole day,
to drive across town, do all that kind of stuff.
So I just feel more plugged in socially to humanity
than I do here.
Yeah, it's less alienating.
Because you know, it's...
Well here, you have to seek out the flow of life,
and in New York, you just walk out the front door
and you're smacked in the face by it.
You can't avoid it, and so you're participating
in the flow of human activity,
whether you want to or not.
Which is exactly what we talked about
at the top of this show.
We are all participating
That's right.
Microbes flowing through
We're all airborne microbes.
The gelatinous cellular matter.
That does sound appetizing.
This is typically the point in the show
where we turn our attention to recapping
whatever the iron cowboy is doing,
but we no longer can afford to do that
because he is no longer waking up every day
and doing an iron man.
No.
What are we gonna do with ourselves?
I wonder what he's doing right now.
We can just keep doing it.
Putting on a little weight and enjoying his life.
What are you doing right now?
Oh, you're still sleeping?
That would be great.
If we just continued with iron iron cowboy updates
on just like, well, I played golf today.
Yeah.
He's probably got like a three handicap
or something silly.
So, yeah, I think he's just a normalizing at the moment,
but what we can do, there are a couple interesting,
prolonged endurance feats that are underway right now.
So we could supplant the iron cowboy by talking about those.
What do you got?
Well, first, what I have, I'm glad you asked
by the way, I've got Robbie Ballenger's Colorado crush,
which is super interesting.
Robbie, former podcast guest,
ultra runner, plant-based beast ran across America.
His name came up in the Hela episode as well.
He's in the midst of this summer long quest
to conquer a series of ultra running challenges
that collectively he's calling the Colorado crush.
And it started with him running the Leadville marathon,
which he completed.
Then he ran the Colorado trail,
which is 500 miles.
He did that, he went back to Leadville
and did the silver rush 50, that was July 11th.
And now he's in the midst of attempting
to summit all 58 peaks in Colorado
that are over 14,000 feet called, fourteeners.
I don't know how many he's done at this point,
but he's knocked off quite a few of them.
He basically wakes up every day and knocks one out.
And he's in a van traveling around
from mountain to mountain.
Is he living in a van?
I think so, him and his wife.
They're just cruising around
in like a converted van at the moment.
Does she run also or she's supporting?
She's supporting.
And he's got Leadville 100 coming up?
And then he's gonna complete it with the Leadville 100,
at the end of August, August 21st.
So three runs.
And just so people know,
like Leadville is at 10,000 feet.
Right.
So this guy's spending a lot of time
at insane altitude.
And a lot of these fourteeners are, you know,
mountaineering is wearing a helmet.
It's not like he's running up, like,
what you would imagine to be a trail.
Some of them are, are pretty crazy in a sense.
Yeah, I mean, most of them have trails though.
I don't think that he's...
No, no, no.
But then you get above the tree line
and you got to boulder and do stuff like that.
Can I shout at someone out it's an Outside editor,
the Outside Magazine editor that, you know,
I guess not really a colleague, I'm so freelance,
but she just left there and is now a freelancer herself
and Dan Schwartz who writes for Outside and others.
They are incredible mountain bikers
and are now taking their mountain bikes onto hiking trails,
single track trails.
And they rode up Mount Elbert,
which is one of those fourteeners.
And it's the first one that they've done
where they're riding their mountain bikes
past hikers that are just like mystified.
And they made it all the way up a fourteener.
It's the first one that they've done.
And I don't know how many people do that out there,
but it seems kind of pioneering and interesting and weird.
And like technically challenging.
Yeah, technically very challenging
Especially when you get above the treeline
and you're going over boulders
and rocks and stuff like that.
So shout out to Gloria and Dan.
We should probably all also shout out Reese Robinson.
Reese is a kid who went on one of our retreats to Italy
several years ago, him and his mom.
And then he came and did a bunch of photo
and video work for us several years ago.
He lived with us for awhile
and he was alongside Robbie on the Colorado trail.
I can't talk today.
And that's 500 miles, North to South?
I don't know that actually, I should know that
Or is it East West.
I'm poorly researched.
But it's a trans Colorado trail.
Yeah, basically.
So, much love Robbie.
We're paying attention, sending you good vibes.
You can check him out on Instagram
where he's sharing his daily experience
at Robbie Balenger, B-A-L-E-N-G-E-R.
And we also have Timothy Olson,
also former podcast guests from way back in the day,
episode 78, which was in 2014.
Crazy awesome ultra runner,
super cool guy with a crazy backstory.
Who's in the midst of an FKT attempt
on the Pacific crest trail.
And he's got about, well, as of yesterday,
he had 250 miles left, which isn't much.
I think he's clocking off at least 30 to 50 miles a day.
And he's doing..
3O to 50?
Yeah
50?
All of these guys are doing double marathons a day
in order to break these FKTs.
Meanwhile, his wife is 35 weeks pregnant
and they're doing this as a family adventure,
which is so...
She's like, okay dude, you can do it,
but I expect 75 a day from here on out.
Clock's ticking, baby's coming,
wherever you are on the trail.
So it's his baby moon.
I guess so right?
Yeah.
I guess so.
Get it in Timothy.
So, those two things.
I think that those are two good things
to take the place of the iron cowboy,
capture people's attention
and send these guys some love.
In a couple of weeks, we'll circle back
on both those, right?
Right.
All right.
So we're gonna take a quick break now.
When we're back, we got a big story.
We got much more to report from the endurance world.
We're also gonna do a summer watch list.
We are doing the Rich Roll summer watch list.
And the Adam Skolnick summer watch list.
It's more like, The Rich Roll summer stream list.
You had mentioned that we should do
like a graphic, like Obama does.
These are the books I read.
Here's the stuff you should be watching.
For your podcast watch list
We'll work on that.
We'll be right back after these words from our sponsors.
We'll be back in a sec, but first,
if you dig this podcast and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book,
"Voicing Change",
featuring excerpts from poignant essays by
and glorious photography of some 50
of my favorite guests over the last
eight plus years of doing this thing, this podcast.
It's a gorgeous artful compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared there,
and all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here
at the RRP and serves as a beautiful keepsake
or gift for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available and we are shipping globally
direct to any coffee table on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
It's so good to be back here with you.
Do you like my, I love carbs, T-shirt?
I love it.
I like that you're like deep in the inside baseball
'cause you're kind of being ironic about the carbs
v protein erroneous, false equivalency
that most plant-based people have to bump up
against when they meet their uncle Tony for ribs.
I mean, he's having ribs,
we're having french fries.
I don't follow any of what you just said.
(laughs)
Don't plant-based people always have to be,
"What do you do for protein?"
"Where do you get your protein?"
It's a clickbait T-shirt because people
are so carb-phobic.
Right.
You know, and they don't realize that actually if you...
You're turning the tables on that protein discussion.
Yes.
It's a picky bars T-shirt, Jesse Thomas send it to me.
I like it.
Yeah.
I actually genuinely love carbs.
I'm not just trying to get clicks, okay?
I love carbs.
You are?
I'll give you some clicks.
I'm happy to give you clicks.
Bagels, sourdough bread, I want it all.
I want all the yeast.
All the yeast?
All the gluten.
I feel you, man.
What is our big story today, Mr. Skolnick?
Our big story.
I like how you showed up with a matching iPad.
I know, but I don't know how to work it.
I have to turn off the WiFi now.
'Cause someone just texted and I'm getting...
Yeah, you gotta turn off notifications.
I know, now I'm getting like Zima baby pictures.
I'm at work, okay?
This is my safe space.
I occasionally get a FaceTime call
when we're in the middle of this.
Not yet today.
Dad, where'd you put the hot sauce?
This is bullshit.
I should just take the FaceTime call next time,
see what happens.
No, not that cupboard, the next...
No, the other, okay.
Big story.
Ready, the big story.
Outer space, Branson, beats Bezos
in the race to see which billionaire
can get to outer space faster and deeper.
That's where we're at.
Did they really go to outer space?
I would call it very much inner space.
Well, James Hamblin says.
Yes.
Who's James Hamblin again?
James Hamblin, he's an author,
he's a preventive medicine doc.
He wrote a book called "Clean",
that was all about his experiment of not using soap
or shampoo or anything like that for a year.
I think he's on the faculty at Yale, I'm not sure,
but he's a very interesting guy, I love following.
Did he get divorced within that year?
No, I don't think so.
No divorce?
No, not that I know.
I think he has a dog.
Did the dog divorce him?
No, why?
No soap for a year, what do you mean why?
(laughs)
Well he wrote a book about,
It's kind of a microbiome oriented thing,
like, we're overly sanitized.
Anyway, he's a great follow on Twitter,
James Hamblin, H-A-M-B-L-I-N.
But he had a great tweet,
which was, billionaires saying they've been to space,
like people saying they've been someplace
because they had a layover in the airport.
Which is kinda true, right?
It's a good tweet.
Like shoot up, you're out there for, you know,
a couple of minutes and then you're back down.
You didn't really go to outer space.
Now, listen, I'm as excited as anybody
that people are going into space.
Yes.
So it is this weird thing.
Like, it's very inspirational and I celebrate
any kind of technological breakthrough,
but you have to balance that against sort of the indulgence
component of it,
especially when it's in the context of billionaires,
competing against each other to who can get out there first.
There's a spectrum of people going out
to the outer spectrum,
there's Branson who got there first.
I think he went 50.
I read about this a little bit ago,
so my stats might be slightly off.
So don't at me.
But I think it was like 53 miles above earth was Branson.
And then Bezos is going 60 plus,
'cause he's in more of a rocket.
So he might be later, but he's gonna go higher.
Right, and then someone actually,
I think I forget who this person is,
but an international billionaire
has effectively chartered a Space X spacecraft,
and they're gonna do like a 10 day orbit.
So there'll be even higher, I believe.
And then there's someone else who's chartering a spaceship
to go to the space station.
So, these are all tourism,
you know, it's on the spectrum of tourism.
None of this is state sponsored or highly trained.
They're definitely getting some training,
but it's not like that highly trained thing.
But in terms of this, to me, it's like,
if you get up to see the curvature of the earth,
you experience zero gravity for a few minutes
or whatever it is, that's space to me.
I mean, if you're fully zero gravity,
you're in the darkness, you're seeing the blue marble,
I mean, you're in space.
Sure.
And there is something monumental about that achievement,
if you just look at it in the vacuum.
And then if you look at the look on the face of Branson
and his colleagues, who he chose
or who somehow got selected, one was like,
the astronaut trainer there was, you know,
one was the communication specialists.
That is two women and two men
from the staff of Virgin Galactic that were Choesen.
And you see how happy and excited and thrilled,
they are, you cannot fake that.
You know, so to me that just shows space.
I'm gonna give them creds.
I'll give space creds.
Listen, there's a lot to celebrate here.
I mean, it's so extraordinary that private industry
has pioneered what, you know, the government
has been unable to execute on.
Ever since we landed on the moon in the 60s
and then NASA kind of faltered for so many years
due to funding or whatever,
and the fact that technology has caught up with this,
you know, obscene, aggregation of wealth
that's allowed these guys to indulge.
I think indulgent is still,
it's still an accurate word, to indulge their fantasies
by pushing technology forward in this way,
whether it's for selfish reasons or competitive reasons
or on behalf of humanity
and the pioneering human spirit,
the result remains the same,
that essentially at the exact same moment
in the grand spectrum of time, you know,
three or four, you know, fat cats
have created competitive rockets to go into space.
I mean, the fact that that Branson went last week
and Bezos is going like, today.
I mean, by the time this podcast goes up,
he will have gone.
♪ Jeffery Bezos. ♪
We're gonna talk about that.
♪ Jeffrey Bezos, ♪
♪ Jeffrey Bezos, you did it! ♪
It's so weird.
It's so bizarre though you know.
(laughs)
I like trolling Bezos.
He's got Blue Origin.
Did you see like Twitter go on it?
They showed his logo.
No.
And his head was like newly shaved and glistening.
And then there's the logo of Blue Origin,
which is vaguely phallic,
and then the rocket was behind him.
It was tri-phallic.
What is with Bezos and phallic iconography?
Like the little arrow on the Amazon thing
is highly phallic.
You know.
What's going on there?
He's the big baller baby.
Big BD.
(laughs)
I will say, that Branson had really beautiful,
huge windows on his craft, didn't he?
Yeah, that's more feminine.
Although I heard something about,
I should have researched this,
but there was that video of him riding his bike
to the launchpad
Branson?
Yeah.
And apparently he didn't actually do that.
Like that was faked.
I don't know.
I will say this,
if you're looking at it from a climate perspective,
there's something both inspiring and grotesque about it.
That's why it's confusing.
Like, I don't have a hard take one way or the other,
like we need to move forward and this is our, you know,
kind of genetic prerogative or disposition, right.
We're always innovating and there's something
to be celebrated in these kinds of breakthroughs.
Like they're unbelievable.
And yet, are they distractions from addressing
the problems that demand our full attention right now?
Would those resources be better directed at, you know,
solving climate problems that are, you know,
that have an immediacy to them?
I mean, did you see those videos of Germany with, you know,
the flooding and the water going
and like the fires that are breaking out so early
in the season and the incredible drought
that we're experiencing here in California.
Every year we notch up in terms of the cataclysms
that we're facing right now.
Did you say something about drought.
I was busy drinking my naturally alkaline
springwater from Erewhon.
You tenderfoot privileged motherfucker, how dare you.
I don't think Gretta's gonna really...
As we sit here outside Malibu, talking into microphones.
Who made this microphone was it made carbon neutral?
Couple of assholes.
No, but like Gretta is not gonna be happy
about the space race.
Of course not.
I kinda want her to like show up as Bezos boards.
You billionaires with your spacecrafts.
Munching caviar, as you look down
on the blue planet that's dying.
Ladies and gentlemen, Gretta as Angela Merkel.
That was good, Angela.
Yeah, I'm not good with the accents.
I liked that, that was great.
But the reason that we're talking about this space story,
I've kind of got a curve ball for you,
because we led with the billionaires, but in reality,
the most interesting space story in my opinion
of the last few weeks are UFOs.
Now in late June, the Pentagon released
an unclassified report prepared by a secret government
program that had been collecting reports
on aerial phenomena since 2007.
Now, before 2007, there was a similar program
that stretched from 52 to 1969,
where 12,000 cases were reported by civilians
or military personnel about unidentified flying objects,
or just aerial phenomenon in general.
And then from 69, nothing happened.
Like he said that period where
kind of nothing really happened.
Yes, we had the space shuttle and all of that,
but the Pentagon was out of the business
of trying to figure out who else is up in outer space.
And then in 2007, they launched this new program.
And there has been, you know, from what I could tell,
7,200 cases reported in the last 15 years or so,
12,000 from 52 to 69, 7200 from 2007 to 2017.
And in 2017, the Trump administration
ordered the Pentagon to declassify
and come up with a report of what's going on.
I like that Trump did that, by the way.
And do you think Trump was trying to find his real dad?
I don't know.
From outer space?
It's kind of a stroke of genius
that he inserted that into some bill
to make sure that this stuff would come out.
He just wanted more conspiracies.
He like tries to hit a conspiracy
that'll work in his favor.
So he orders that, and it just was revealed,
the report came out in June and in that report,
most of them are explained away as natural phenomena
or military classified military drills
that people didn't know about
and they couldn't really tell them.
So they just let the conspiracy filter.
But there's like over a hundred.
I can't remember from that Kevin Reus,
that he sat in at the daily,
but it was over a hundred that they don't know what it was.
Right, well we've all seen the video
from like, I don't remember everybody's name,
'cause this is a curve ball
and I didn't like write all this stuff down.
But the video from the fighter pilots,
where multiple pilots are seeing the same thing
at the same time and they're discussing it.
And the thing goes, you know, it just drops precipitously
at an insane, you know, velocity
and doing all sorts of things
that no manmade vehicle is capable of.
And there's a lot of confusion
and wonder about what actually is going on.
Like it's kind of amazing.
It is amazing.
So on one level, if you look at it,
you think I've been waiting my whole for UFOs
to be discovered, I guess we're calling
them UAPs now, right?
Yeah
Unidentified aerial phenomena.
Yes, because some of them are not flying objects.
Some of them could be natural, phenomena.
So there's an argument to be made
that we shouldn't really be talking
about anything else, but this.
If you could verify that these truly are alien.
It would just absolutely change everything.
But then we just go right on to Twitter scrolling.
Well, that's cool.
I think before we get to that,
let's get the one thing out of the way here,
does Rich Roll believe in life from other planets
and UFOs.
Well, to quote Mulder,
I wanna believe, Adam.
I wanna believe.
I mean, just by sheer numbers.
Yeah.
I have to believe that it's possible,
when you think of the billions and the trillions
of stars and galaxies and solar systems
that are out there.
Yeah.
The percentages are very much in favor
of some type of life form being somewhere.
Some type of intelligent life form.
Yeah intelligent life form.
I think where it gets tricky is that,
we project our idea of what intelligent life form means.
It's true.
We're basing it on a carbon
based life form, and we imagine it will have,
you know, appendages and limbs and a brain and all that.
Not me, I think of whales.
You think of whales?
Well, that has a brain,
It has a big brain, right?
Yes.
How we conceptualize an organic organism,
I think is limited
and I think we're limited by the capacity
of our own brains.
Like, there's so much about physics
that we still truly are baffled by
including dark matter, et cetera.
So, you know, we're endeavoring to try to understand
the mysteries of the universe, but I think
we're limited in the same way that
the brain of a snake is never gonna be able
to understand human language.
Like it exceeds the capacity of that organism to comprehend.
And I think we have huge limitations in our ability
to comprehend everything.
Yes.
Perhaps technology can serve as a proxy
to help us better understand certain things
that are beyond our capabilities.
But I think there's a certain hubris with human beings
that we think we could be all knowing
when in fact we're handicapped in ways
that we're not even aware of.
So, that being said,
my point being that, life forms could take a shape
and a structure that is beyond anything
that we've contemplated or could contemplate.
So when we think of UFO's and flying saucers
and what we see in the movies and on television,
that's a pretty limited imagination
of what's actually truly possible.
Spielberg is gonna be so pissed
when he hears you say that.
Like, first of all, if somebody is gonna say like,
we're already doing drones, right?
So, if these UAPs truly are alien,
we can't assume that they're manned
in a way that we would understand them to be,
why would they do that?
Right.
And why would they care about us?
Are they observing us in the way
that we observe an anthill?
It's more like Chris Columbus,
just bumbling their way to discovery.
You think so?
It's just a total accident.
You don't think it's more strategic than that.
No no, if they're as intelligent
as we are, it's just human.
It's just alien error, just like human error.
Like accidentally, they got here.
You're projecting a human sensibility
onto an alien intelligence.
I just think life bumbles its way forward.
Evolution, that's the one thing that Darwin forgot
to get into in evolution, accidental evolution.
(laughs) Most people just evolve accidentally.
Well that's what natural selection is.
You know, competition and selection.
We select for the happenstance genes that are favorable.
But I'm with you though.
I can't believe that there's so many stars out there,
so many galaxies and there's not another planet
like with really good music, you know,
and like good restaurants.
Yeah, so that capsule that's floating
out in space right now that has the phonograph
that's playing music,
you think that'll ever find an audience?
No, I think there's gotta be life out there.
There's gotta be intelligent life.
It's gotta happen, it's gotta be.
Like, I can't see how it wouldn't.
It's pretty silly to think that we're the only game
in the universe.
Right.
It seems ridiculous.
Well, we seem to be on this trajectory,
hurdling towards self-destruction and just basically,
you know, imploding our planet.
But what if we're the younger sibling in all of this
and, you know, other forms of us out there
have all done the same, far in the past.
and we're the sole remaining viable planet,
because this has repeated itself
time and time and time again.
We're going so deep right now.
That's a very dark and depressing way to look at it.
It's gonna be more like a Mars attacks thing.
Remember Mars attacks,
where Jack NiChoelson's the president.
Everyone's all like, I knew the aliens are good
it's gonna be beautiful, we love you.
And then they attack.
I watched "Independence day", the other day
with my daughter and her boyfriend.
Oh, nice.
I forgot how much fun that movie is.
I haven't seen that in so long.
You know Will Smith doesn't come on screen
in that movie until like 25 minutes in.
Yeah, he has to fix it.
He does fix it in the end.
Perhaps the greatest president performance in a movie,
Bill Pullman delivering his speech
and then becoming the pilot at the end.
You're going Bill Pullman as the greatest president.
Maybe not.
Among, I would say definitely among the greatest
cinematic presidents in that movie.
So Bill Pullman then Daniel Day Lewis as Abe Lincoln.
No, I don't know about that.
I mean, maybe acting performance.
I'm talking about like, you know,
the guy in the White House, sitting president,
who's gotta make hard decisions.
And he does a good job.
Yeah.
If only there was a script when things got hard.
I don't know, we got off track here.
This is perfect track.
We're headed towards
the summer watch list.
It is crazy that
there are all these sightings
and it's really hard to dismiss.
And when you have legitimate military pilots
and high ranking officers
who are taking this stuff seriously,
it does give you pause.
It does.
It's unbelievable and yet at the same time,
and this argument has been made by many,
everybody's got a 4K camera in their pocket right now.
And yet every image and video clip
that we see still looks like the fuzzy stuff
that we saw as kids.
I mean, I used to buy these little books about UFO,
I was obsessed, you know.
You did?
And they're all so grainy.
Tell us about that.
You used to buy little UFO,
Little Rich used to buy UFO books.
Yeah yeah yeah
I went down a UFO rabbit hole as a kid.
Really, how old were you?
Yeah, I don't know, 12, 10.
Did you used to draw them.
No, but I got really into Star Trek.
Oh really.
I went to Star Trek conventions
Did you really?
I did.
Did you dress like...
I made my dad take me to a Star Trek convention.
Who were you?
Were you Spock?
I didn't dress up.
I vividly remember my dad just being baffled
because there were grown men and women
in full Star Trek costume,
as we wandered the convention hall at this thing.
Dude, I want the archival footage.
You know, if you ever go on David Shore show.
We're gonna talk about that.
He would find couple of footage of you
in a Star Trek outfit.
I don't think so.
But back to the point,
no crisp definitive video footage
when everybody has a cell phone in their pocket.
And why did these things always happen over, you know,
desolate areas of the ocean?
Those recent ones that the military captured,
I think were off the coast of San Diego, right.
Or over some cornfield.
Which does make sense
because San Diego is a nice place to visit.
And if you're gonna come to the earth,
San Diego would be high up on the list.
Well then, why not be right over San Diego?
Why are you 20 miles off shore?
Like near a military base.
So you're saying it's some sort of spy craft.
I don't know are we getting anywhere with this?
The whole point is not to get anywhere
it's to entertain people with your musings on outer space.
I don't know that I have any take on this,
that everybody else doesn't have.
I mean, I do wanna believe,
and I think it's fascinating and it is wild
that the government, in fact, has been collecting
all of this information in a systematic way
for a very long period of time.
And my understanding,
I wish I'd done a little bit more research on this, is that
that report that came out is only part of the picture.
Like there's still a bunch of classified information
that they haven't disclosed.
Right, exactly.
So what is that about?
And why aren't they disclosing that?
What does that say?
I think that's in the sequel, the report's sequel.
Are they ever gonna release that
or is that just wrapped up?
Now you've gone from Mulder and Scully
and you're into Tommy Lee Jones Will Smith category
in that next report.
I like that mash up.
Men in black.
So before we date ourselves with more old content,
I wanna ask one thing, because me personally,
when I heard from someone I met actually at swim run,
who works at Space X told me about,
it was the first person to tell me about this,
this group of people that's going to be orbiting
on the Space X spacecraft.
And I thought, God, that would be so cool
to be the journalists,
like to be the old, kind of like, the log book writer.
What do they call that?
The scribe that's brought along
on the, you know, trans continental shift ship,
to write about life on the ship.
It would be so fun to do that.
Like I would go check it out, like even though...
Would you go up in the craft though.
I would go up.
Someone's gonna die.
One of these things is gonna explode.
I agree, It's gonna happen.
Yeah it's built into it.
I mean, part of the Space X model was building
into the budget, that a certain number
of these rockets are gonna explode.
It's part of this journey, right?
We've seen that the unmanned ones explode.
Right.
We've seen it.
It's going to happen.
So, is a billionaire going to die doing this?
Yes, 100%, no question.
But you'd go up in it anyway, right?
But it's not going to be Bezos, his luck's too good.
He just stepped down as CEO though, the timing.
♪ Jeffery Bezos. ♪
(laughs)
All right, that's a good segue
to get into what we're gonna talk about next,
which is our summer watch list.
The must streams.
Yes, first annual Rich Roll
summer stream list, must streams.
We both made a lists of things that have captured
our fascination and attention
and things that we think are worthy
of you guys checking out.
Some of which you know,
are very much in the zeitgeists
and perhaps you've already seen,
some of which are a little bit off the beaten path,
but at the very top of my list is Bo Burnham's inside.
This thing haunts me.
Like I saw it maybe, I don't know,
three weeks ago.
When did I text you and said like, I...
It was right after we recorded last time.
It was like the weekend after.
I think it was about three or four weeks ago.
I can't stop thinking about.
Oh my God.
It's unbelievable.
I truly think this is a master work,
what this guy accomplished.
And for people that aren't familiar,
Bo Burnham is a stand-up comedian,
he's a film director,
he's a writer, he's done many things.
He's kind of a theater kid who grew up on the internet
and went viral as a young kid,
singing songs and telling jokes,
on YouTube and on Vine and has matured
into a pretty prominent talent in Hollywood.
He wrote and directed the movie eighth grade, which I loved.
I thought it was magical and a really special movie.
And he's done a number of comedy specials over the years,
but this comedy special,
and I hesitate to even call it a comedy special 'cause
I don't really think that that captures what exactly it is.
It's sort of a private concert film.
There is a comedy special component to it,
but it's performance art, it's isolation, theater
and it really is cinema.
But DIY cinema.
Very DIY.
He basically took the pandemic year
to create this special.
He did the entire thing
in his little guest house where he lit it,
he shot it, he wrote it, he performed it,
he edited it and created this really compelling
multilayered, profound piece of art that I don't know,
I'm at a loss to figuring out the language to describe it
because it is so unlike anything I've ever seen.
And I think it entertains and operates on so many levels.
And the reason why it haunts me and has stayed with me
is because of that multi-layered aspect to it.
Like you can watch it on its surface
and be entertained by it,
but the more you think about it, the more you realize,
like, how deep he's probing issues of isolation,
issues of internet culture, youth culture, depression,
loneliness, suicide, and you know,
the attention seeking that is part and parcel
of his generation, as somebody, I think he was born in 1990,
grew up on the internet.
The internet has always been,
you know, who he is and where he has gone
to perform and this interesting, difficult,
challenging relationship that he has with social media
in the sense that it birthed him
and has given him this outlet,
and yet it's also so destructive
and emotionally debilitating at the same time.
And he probes all of this stuff with songs,
with interludes, with, you know,
think pieces that are peppered throughout this whole thing.
And you see this trajectory from, you know,
it kinda opens and he's in a...
It's relatively light and gleeful as it begins
and there's a slow degradation of his mental wellbeing
throughout the course of the hour until, you know,
he's quite despondent at the end and has to find,
you know, some salvation.
But I think it's kind of like, you can sense
the darkness in it really early.
I mean, it is a very, to say it's very dark
is not to put you off.
It's dark, but in a way that great art
has to be in a way.
It's the most honest,
I think the best piece of satire for the internet age
that we have seen.
Nothing I think, that I've seen can even come close
to the commentary that's in this.
It just shows you how, you know,
this is like, who was the first comic to swear?
You know, like Lenny Bruce, like this is like to me,
for sure, all time, great comedy work of art.
You know, it's like, for of its age,
there's nothing that even comes close
to being able to push buttons like this
that I've seen in a long time.
It's such a trope to say voice of a generation.
You know, it's such a trite turn of phrase,
but I think it is apropos in his case
and the case of this work.
I mean, it's unbelievably,
self-referential it's meta and the level of self-awareness
that he brings to it.
Like the idea is that he is authentically performing
and bearing his vulnerable self
while also reviewing it at the same time.
So it folds in on itself.
And he's also letting you know that
he knows that at the same time.
So it begs the question of what is truly authentic?
Is this vulnerability true or is this a performance?
And you're not quite sure where that lies.
Like when he's breaking down,
is he really breaking down or is he winking at you
and saying, this is part of the performance as well.
Right.
I mean, as a performance art piece,
it doesn't even really matter.
Like there was some blowback I heard
that people were saying, "Oh, you know,
"he's trying to pretend that he's lived
"in that room for the whole year."
"And it's actually a guest house,
"really nice house."
"And he has a partner that he lives with
"and he's got a great life
"and he's not depressed like that."
And I'm like, well, first of all,
you can't fake that kind of introspection and a genius
and it usually does come with a very big dark side
and he grew up religious too.
So like, that is in there as well.
And, from what I read, I don't wanna speak for him,
but that's what I read.
So, to me that kind of criticism,
which is there's always going to be haters,
but I did hear there was pushback on him.
I'm like, this is a piece of art, like you know,
for you to try to say that it's like, it doesn't have...
But also that's part of the art,
that's part of the conversation.
Like that self-awareness extends to his understanding.
He knows that the audience knows that he has a partner,
who's a successful film director and that he probably,
you know, makes quite a bit of money doing what he does.
So is this performance, is it real?
And where is that line?
I mean, it almost doesn't matter.
The commentary remains, you know, significant,
I think, whether or not it's true
to the extent to which it's true,
but I think you're correct.
Like he was degrading, you know,
and it's this confluence or this overlap of analyzing
how the internet impacts all of us
in that self-referential way.
Him as observer, but also participant at the same time,
a commentary on the pandemic and the progressive isolation
and mental and emotional despair
that goes hand in hand with that.
Yeah, and then, you know, two songs,
one is, welcome to the internet, which starts
with a polka, welcome to the internet.
And he goes into this, you know, this quote you have here,
"could I interest you in everything all of the time,
"a little bit of everything, all of the time,
"apathy is a tragedy and boredom is a crime,
"anything and everything all of the time."
I mean, that song might be the single best
critique of the internet I've ever seen or heard.
And it goes on and on and on and it's amazing.
You can't say enough how great the songs are.
They're like ear worms and they're satire.
Like, you don't really tend to listen
to like comedy songs for fun,
but it's deeper than that.
And you know, whether it's that one
or white girl's Instagram.
The Bezos song.
I mean, white girl's Instagram is probably
the catchiest one.
I'm sure on YouTube, it's got insane views at this point.
I wanna sing them all.
He makes this music video of this song,
you know, white girl's Instagram,
that is just so on the nose.
It's amazing.
It's unbelievable.
And then he uses Auto-Tune,
which you know, is also part of his satire.
And what's amazing.
He did that onstage in another show that he did,
where he was sort of doing commentary
on Kanye and he started doing this Auto-Tune song
about why the Pringles jar wasn't wide enough
for your hand to go in it.
'Cause people on the internet are doing
auto-tuned stuff on loop.
And also he self flagellates himself
in this martyr, you know, this sort of satirical,
I'm a martyr white guy, like I'm aware like,
should I be talking about social justice issues,
but I'm a white guy,
no one needs to hear from me.
Like that internal battle that he's having
that is layered with the fact that over time,
like he's had missteps on the internet and said jokes that,
you know, were inappropriate or whatever,
as somebody who grew up, like his whole life,
the guys not performing on YouTube.
So as a kid, you know,
you're gonna look back on that stuff and cringe.
So now here he is, you know, growing up and he turns 30,
like while the plot unfolds.
And what does that mean?
Like to be an adult and look back on this, you know,
chronicle of your life that plays out in the digital space
and a big part or recurring theme of the show
is him watching himself,
which is this beautiful poignant metaphor
for how we all are learning how to navigate
the intersection of our three-dimensional lives
and our digital lives.
Right?
Yeah.
So this idea that he's, you know,
there's this authentic burst of originality and creativity,
and then you see him watching himself on a laptop
and editing it, you know,
and isn't that the perfect statement
for what this is all about.
Right, I mean, he makes fun of Twitch,
he makes fun of like everything.
He makes fun of like YouTube, a wrap-up commentary,
like whatever.
The commentary video where he's singing
and then he pops up in the corner
and he's doing a reaction video to his video.
And then it just continues to tile.
He's reacting to the reacting video.
It's so good.
Like that's the meta, you know,
kind of space that we're in.
And then when he's a Twitch streamer
and he's the video game character.
And as the Twitch streamer, he's like,
I'm gonna make him cry.
Yeah.
You know, fast forward to later,
in the arc where he actually cries
and has this, you know, emotional breakdown.
I think there's definitely depression in his makeup
somewhere because I don't think you can really
fake it that well.
And I think he's more channeling what might've happened
in his life to make great art versus pretending
things have to happen.
And which is what great acting is.
And I think, you know,
in addition to welcome to the internet,
there's that funny feeling,
which is kind of similar type song,
but more of a, like an acoustic song,
but it's more about the smartphone.
You know, and it's the same idea though.
See, to me, it's more like,
it's not really about learning to deal with this new space
that we all find ourselves in self-referential space,
it's more like, this is a bad idea.
Right, yeah.
Like this is going wrong.
It's not like.
Clearly.
It's not going to end well.
It doesn't end well,
and a couple of interesting observations on that.
First of all, he did zero press on this.
Right.
As far as I could tell, he didn't do any interviews.
He just put it out there on Netflix.
It exploded, everybody's talking about it.
But it's not like he went and did a bunch of talk shows
or podcasts.
He's done that in the past.
He did that for eighth grade.
He did a whole promotional tour.
He's not one who, you know, isn't experienced
doing that kind of thing.
But in this case, he just like,
put it out there and has said nothing
like a true artist.
Amazing.
Which I think is fucking cool
as much as I'd like to have him on the podcast.
You know, clearly he's not doing that.
And I think there's this, yes,
this is what social media and the internet is doing to us.
And there's kind of a beautiful, you know,
third act sequence in here.
I mean, thinking of this much like
a Sartre play, ** like he's stuck in this house,
he can't get out of it.
He's struggling to open the door and get out
and every time he pokes, he looks out the window,
he shuts the shades again.
He finally summons the courage to get out
at the end he gets out.
And what does he do?
He immediately tries to get back in.
And that idea, I think he says it outright in the show
that we're now living in a world
in which the only reason to go outside
is to gather resources, collect the resources required
so you can come back in and fortify your digital life.
That's very interesting and crazy
to think about it like that.
It's true.
Yeah
It's like the digital life
and he gets into sexting
and some of this stuff is like,
even without the pandemic would be voice
of the generation type stuff, you know what I mean?
Like, because there is more isolation
even before the pandemic, but after the pandemic,
we all feel like, wow, what we wanna go out,
but what's it like?
Some people are probably diving into it
and getting back out there,
but more people it's a one-step for sure.
We've acclimated to a more immersive digital life
and how many people are gonna just double down on that
as, you know, if and when the world opens back up.
So I wrote down a couple of things I can think of,
like in terms of where this fits in the pantheon, you know,
all time, great specials.
You have Richard Pryor live at the sunset strip,
Eddie Murphy's delirious, Robin Williams at the Met,
Chris Rock special when he had four cities,
Allie Wong's Baby Cobra, I think was ** incredible.
But this is less straight comedy like that you know.
This is more performance art too.
So then you have Sandra Bernhardt and John Leguizamo's
one man show from the 90s.
But this, it's funnier than those two
and it's as funny as any of the best standup comedy
performances, but it also has that performance art
and he's making it himself.
I think it's the most wildly original,
brilliant comedy special I've ever seen.
Well, I struggle with even comparing
it to those other stand-up comedians because
it is so different.
To me, it's more like Peter Boghossian
or, what's his name?
Sterling, the walking to Cambodia guy.
What's his name?
I don't know.
Look that up.
He was a one man show guy, Tribeca, you know,
theater dude, who did a bunch of one man shows
that were pretty profound,
like back in the early 80s.
Okay.
Who was kind of a contemporary
of David Byrne and you know,
some other interesting people like that.
Anyway, it stands on its own.
And I think what distinguishes it even more
is the cinematic quality to it.
Like it really is a movie and the intentionality
that he brings into the lighting and the camera framing
and the interludes in between these musical numbers
and sequences are those quiet moments.
And I think those say as much about who he is
and where our culture is, than the big
kind of splashy numbers themselves.
I agree.
I mean, the lighting is spectacular.
It's insane.
Yeah, like what he can do
with just a couple things it's...
Yeah, so congrats to Bo Burnham
on an incredible piece of work and it's a must see,
it's a must stream.
A final thought on that,
and you know, I'm probably spoiling it
for people who haven't seen it.
Not that there's really anything to spoil
because it's so experiential,
it's not about plot or anything like that,
but you know, when I say it's haunted me,
there's that clip of him where he's sitting
and he's watching like his first video
when he was a kid playing piano,
and you're just like your heart breaks
and you wonder, what is he thinking about that?
And how does that inform what he does now?
And the whole thing ends with him sitting.
There's a close-up on his face
and he's watching the finished special,
like he's reviewing it again.
And again, it's that like,
we're always observing ourselves
as authentic as we're trying to be,
we're creating a calculated version
of whatever message we're trying to put out there.
And the very last frame is him cracking the slightest smile,
like just a little smile and you can tell he's pleased.
Like he's pleased with this thing that he created
as painful and as hard rot as it might have been.
He knows that he said what he wanted to say,
and it's kind of a beautiful way to end
what is a very dark and disturbing
and at times depressing look at, you know,
the gestalt of culture.
Anyway, I can't recommend it enough.
We should probably add a spoiler alert
at some point top.
No, I mean, you know, whatever, listen,
regardless of any of that,
I don't think any of that spoils it,
because like I said,
it's not a plot driven thing.
It's an experiential thing.
I will also say that as much as I was impacted by it,
like my boys who are 26 and 25 and more, you know,
in the age range of Bo like absolutely loved it.
They can't stop talking about it.
My 14 year old,
like totally dug it, it's very meaningful to Jaya.
So it operates on different levels
for different age groups.
And I think for young people,
because we're older and we don't have that relationship
to the internet, even though a substantial
portion of what I do is online,
there is something about,
there's a relatability I think for Gen Z
and perhaps even millennials who will be able
to connect with his message in a way that,
you know, even as impactful as it was for me,
that I can't access.
I think as we go through this list,
one thing that kind of ties it all together
is archival footage.
And the fact that in every one of these instances.
Their entire life is documented,
Incredible archival footage yeah.
It's like, we all have footage like that somewhere.
You know, like a lot of us.
But not like him.
If you're 15 years old right now,
your entire life is sitting in the cloud.
Speaking of archival footage,
that's a good moment to pivot to the next must-watch
of the summer, which is Roadrunner,
the new Bordain documentary.
That thing is rife with so much archival footage.
It was shocking just how much of Anthony Bourdain's
trajectory was captured on film
because the documentary tracks his arc
from the early days when he was the chef at Le Halles,
I think that's how you say it,
all the way through all of his successes
and ultimately his demise.
And I love the documentary.
Jeff Gordon invited me to a press screening
when I was in New York City the week before it came out.
It's now out in theaters now.
I don't think it's streaming,
I'm not sure it will be soon.
I was very moved by this.
I mean, I would suspect like you,
Anthony Bordain, you know, holds a large place
in my consciousness.
His passing`was a tough one,
I think for all of us.
And I don't quite know what it is about him,
but he was able to connect with so many people
in such a profound, meaningful way.
And I think the documentary does a really good job
of helping you understand who this guy was,
and what made him tick.
You have not had a chance to see this.
I've not seen it yet, 'cause it's not streaming
and I only stay at home.
(laughs)
You're here now.
Oh, wait, I got outside.
I go home or to the beach Rich, that's what I do.
Right.
You've never met Anthony Bordain.
I've never met him.
No, I never met him.
But you know, as us lonely planet writers,
like we're like the road warrior hacks
of going to places that he's gone to with his crew
and eating at some of these similar restaurants
and finding that like ethnic food that nobody sees.
You know, that Jonathan gold here in L.A.
and the Anthony Bordain overseas aesthetic
figures prominently in almost all lonely planet writers.
I mean that's what we aspire to and did in our own way
and express in our own way.
So very kindred spirit stuff there.
And obviously the work itself is great.
And then he's got the kind of somewhat Taoist,
Eastern philosophy that he's,
appropriated is the wrong word,
'cause he actually cared about it and studied it
and so I can relate to that.
And so, you know, definitely when he died,
it was shocking to be honest with you and sad.
But someone I always sort of admired
and continue to admire.
And I'll watch anything with him in it.
So I'm really looking forward to this.
Yeah, just utterly compelling to watch him,
a captivating, charismatic personality
who had this expansive joy for experiences of all kinds.
And irrespective of however successful
he became, was really just like one of us,
like he was an every man
and he was much more interested in having a conversation
with a random guy on the street
than he was about going to some velvet rope event.
And I think what's interesting about him,
and the documentary affirms this take
that I've always had, which is that this guy essentially
was an untreated alcoholic.
I mean, I'm convinced that this was the case.
Oh yeah, big drinker.
So he had this heroin problem.
He kicked heroin.
He kicked hard drugs.
But without going to narcotics anonymous,
But he's this extreme personality.
And that ism inside of him divorced itself
from hardcore substances,
but remained active and would latch onto anything
and everything that could kind of take him out
of whatever emotional disaffectation he was experiencing.
And that extremism made him this larger
than life personality.
So, it was, in many ways, his strength
and what endeared all of us to him so profoundly,
but also ultimately, you know,
paved the way for, for his demise.
I mean, he continued to drink and, you know,
smoke pot and stuff like that.
So it wasn't like he actually got sober,
but you see over the course of this documentary,
how he latches on to certain, not just substances,
but people, experiences.
Like he goes from being just the guy who's just smokes
like crazy to being an insane jujitsu practitioner.
And that becomes his obsession,
a healthier obsession of course,
than some of his other ones.
Travel experiences that obviously underscore, you know,
why those television shows that he did,
impacted so many people.
But, you know, a brooding dark guy
who was an incredible writer and an incredible friend.
And thinker.
Thinker.
The person who would really invest a lot of time
into his friendships and really was curious
about what made other people tick
and really appreciated his friends, I think,
in a way that we can all learn from.
But I think ultimately where it all really begins to unravel
is when he gets involved with Asia Argento
near the end, and she becomes his obsession
and he remarks early in that relationship,
a self-awareness that this potentially could be his demise
and the documentary, I won't spoil it,
but it kind of plays this out
and you see how everything starts to line up for him
to meet his fateful end.
Was he an escapist?
'Cause I think about escapism a lot.
'Cause I think I have that in me.
I think escapism can mean different things.
I mean, I look at it, as I always say, through the lens
of recovery and addiction.
And I just see somebody who is an untreated addict
and had a profound, you know,
whether it's a hole in your spirit or an inability
to just sit with yourself that drove a lot of those
wild experiences and, you know, compelled him
to go to places other people wouldn't go,
you know, like Beirut when it's, you know,
being bombed and places like that.
That's part of like, that's a very addict thing.
Like I need to be where the action is.
I need to get with the most dramatic woman, you know.
I need to be where the action is happening
and that's exciting and it's intoxicating
and it's ultimately a distraction
for whatever emotional issues you're having,
because you don't have to sit with yourself
and deal with yourself.
And you see the pain and the tension between that pole,
that drive inside of him and the fact that
he has a wife and he has a kid
and the, what's the right word for it?
The kind of...
He tortures himself over his relationship with child
in that, he's not sure he's being a good dad
and he so desperately wants to be a good dad.
And yet, you know, he has this huge life
that all of us look out and say,
I would be happy if I had that life.
And you realize that, that life is disconnected
from whether or not, you're gonna be happy
because that's the relationship between you and you
and it has nothing to do with the externalities
that are swirling around that guy or any of us.
You know, having lived on the road for eight months
a year for seven to eight years,
as a lonely planet author.
Eight, nine months and you're chasing
like cool destinations and going weirder
and weirder places, that I call it weirder and weirder.
More unusual places, it's a better way of putting it
to get further and further away from the known world,
or our own culture and our own selves.
You know, a lot of people call that the dream job,
most people wouldn't last one year doing that.
You know, to last seven or eight years was a lot for me.
There's people out there still doing it that I know,
although the pandemic has halted a lot of those contracts.
But most people would not last one year.
You know, the New York times had the 52 places journalists,
and a lot of them have written about it afterwards.
And a lot of them were, I mean, so far,
I think they were pretty exhausted by the end
and wouldn't necessarily recommend it as a great lifestyle.
Like lonely planet, lonely writer.
Well it's like Jeff Gordinier said
about like needing a healthier lifestyle after years
of eating and being a great food critic.
And, you know, he taps into some of that same stuff.
It's different than that because we're not getting
that same, but you do get some of those meals, you know.
So you do have a little bit,
'cause we're writing about food,
but we're also staying in crappy places and nice places,
you know, we're on the ferries,
we're on the, the rickety airplanes you read about it.
I can't tell you how many Indonesia flights I took
and after every trip to Indonesia,
'cause Indonesia has a very bad air safety record,
you could look it up, it's not good at all.
And after every trip over there, when I've done
30 domestic flights, I'm happy that I made it out.
(laughs)
You know, like that kind of stuff,
but that's part of the appeal too.
In the end, you know,
there is an element like I want to do that,
I love the fact I live in a small place in LA
and I can open the door and the doors to the whole world.
But you do lose track.
My situation came with a failed marriage,
It came with missing lots of weddings of friends,
it came with missing birthdays and holidays.
And, you know, I couldn't imagine doing that
with Zoom at home now.
Sure, you're also not an addict,
you know what I mean?
Imagine the guy who's like, "Oh my God,
"I'm gonna get on this plane and it might crash,
"let's get in it."
You know, that's the difference.
Right, right, right.
Yeah, maybe not.
There's a sequence in the movie where they go to the Congo
and they kind of walked through that very predicament.
Is that right?
Yeah.
But I'm not an addict, you're right.
I'm not in that level, but I can understand
that chasm between your life
and the connections in your world.
So I'm really looking forward to this.
Now, there is a controversy
Yes.
That came up, late game controversy,
where apparently, a couple of emails that he wrote,
they went to AI and deep faked his voice.
They fed this program, all this recorded stuff
that he spoke, all his narration
from different bunch of files.
Maybe it was like dozens of hours.
And it came up with a deep fake of Bourdain's voice
to narrate his own emails.
And the family or the people connected to Bourdain
are saying that wasn't approved.
The director says it was approved.
Does that disturb you?
Does it change the way you look at the movie?
I think that they shouldn't have done it.
I think it was wrong headed of the director
to go in that direction.
I guess I could understand why.
It's like he wanted to animate these words that Bourdain
had written and what better way to do it than
to put it into his voice.
He never actually said them out loud.
But when you're making a movie and you wanna show
rather than tell, I can see why
that would be a creative Choeice.
But my sense is that they didn't really
completely think it through.
So the director said,
we cleared this with the estate, et cetera,
everybody was cool with it.
The family says something differently.
The consensus is essentially that this is something
that Bourdain who is, you know,
the very emblem of authenticity would not be into.
Like, the idea that he would be resurrected
from the grave to say something that he never actually said,
even though he actually wrote it,
I think was, you know, perhaps in poor taste,
I think the wrong creative Choeice,
I think that it could have been ameliorated if he decided
that he still wanted to use that as a storytelling device
to put a caption in the movie itself to say
we recreated this off of, you know,
an algorithm or something like that, to let the audience
know so there was some transparency in it.
I saw the movie before this controversy came out.
So I was unaware that completely.
So my screening of it was not informed by that awareness
going into it.
You lost yourself in the movie more than like,
if you'd known.
Had I known going into it, would my reaction
to the movie differently?
I'd like to think not.
To me, this was a mistake,
but I don't think that it should cloud people's...
It shouldn't be a reason to not see the movie.
Like, I think it's a distraction.
Like it's a beautiful work of art.
Like this movie is actually really quite good
and I was very moved by it
and I want everybody to see it
because it's an extraordinary chronicle
of one of the most iconic figures of our time.
I think one of the most charismatic figures
last 30, 50 years.
Yeah, absolutely.
To the extent that this is a controversy
that would motivate people not to see the movie
or to protest the movie,
I think is wrong-headed.
Fair enough.
So, they shouldn't have done it.
You know I'm not happy that it happened.
It could have been handled in different ways,
but don't let it be a reason to not see the movie
'cause the movie, you know, standing on its own two feet,
outside of that controversy is really worth seeing.
I separate the offense as like someone who doesn't
understand the harm that deep fakes could cause.
The problem is, it is kind of a hand grenade.
Yeah, and it's sort of like,
oh, this was slipped in here
and no one said anything about it.
So what's gonna happen five or 10 years?
And how is this gonna work its way
into other works of art?
And is there an obligation to be transparent about this,
if you're gonna do it or should we not do it at all?
And I think that's an important conversation.
Exactly, so big picture,
the criticism of it is good and important
because hopefully it'll scare off other people
from doing this
Yeah, next time, you know,
directors will think twice, as they should.
A couple, before we segue.
A couple of the characters that pop up in this movie,
you've got David Chang who I always love.
Like David Chang's best man.
Every time he talks, I can listen to that guy
tell stories and talk about.
Do you watch his show?
I've watched some of it, I listened to his podcasts.
I'm a huge fan.
And the other David, David Choe is also in this movie.
Talk about charismatic.
Like that guy is captivating.
Like he figures prominently in the Bourdain doc
and as part of a sequence that, that ends the movie,
that just leaves you wrecked.
Really?
There's something about David,
he allows himself to be so emotionally vulnerable,
like nothing is off the table and he'll tell you everything.
And his emotions are just right on the surface,
talking about Anthony and his relationship with him.
I found to be very impactful.
There's also a short sequence with Iggy Pop
in the documentary.
That's beautiful.
But Iggy Pop drops a crazy truth on Anthony Bourdain
that I can't stop thinking about, but I won't spoil it.
That in and of itself, is worth the price
of admission to this movie.
That's speaking of David Choe.
Yes.
We're gonna go from the Bordain doc
and David Choe's appearance in that movie,
right into the Choe show.
The Choe show, baby.
How do you feel about the Choe show?
You know, I was skeptical.
I was skeptical going into it because of his backstory.
I don't know, the backstory being
he's this graffiti artist that, I think got famous at first
'cause he went to Facebook headquarters
and he did a piece and got paid in stocks.
So what happened was, he got hired,
he was a young artist,
and he got hired by not just Facebook,
but I think Zuckerberg personally
and maybe some other people
in that kind of startup Silicon valley world,
like a bunch of high net worth people,
but he came to Facebook and he painted a bunch of murals
and stairwells and things like that.
And he took stock instead of cash.
And when Facebook went public.
Which they would never do anymore.
No. (Adam laughs)
Pre-share
So those shares, when Facebook went public,
were worth $200 million.
Unbelievable.
So he made $200 million.
For painting their office.
Had he not, he sold those shares and cashed out,
had he held onto those shares,
you know, what they would be worth today?
I have no idea.
$1.3 billion, that's how crazy that is.
So he's both a genius and he screwed up.
Well, he's definitely a genius
and he's definitely screwed up
and that's part of his term and his charisma.
I don't think he'd want the one point two.
I cannot look away from this guy.
Everything that I see him in every interview.
He was on Rogan, I think he's gotten a Rogan
a couple of times, fascinating.
Absolutely fascinating figure.
This show is so wild and original,
so chaotic it's like you're dropped into his brain
and you're living in his brain
and he's living in his brain and everyone
gets invited in.
I wasn't prepared for how brilliant it was.
I thought it was going to be a vehicle
for a guy who like, does cool art.
I wasn't prepared for it
'cause I didn't know much about him.
And all I knew was that story that everyone talks about.
And I knew that he had some weird thing with women
that came out, and he dresses that head-on.
He also had a podcast for a while,
that was completely off the rails.
Okay yeah, and I just thought maybe
it's gonna be too weird for me,
but it's not it's like right up my alley.
The one thing I'll say, and I'll spin it back to you,
is that he lives in his childhood home.
And the reason that's poignant for me is that we just moved
into my childhood home.
I'm renting my child home right now.
And I mean, he bought his,
and we don't know the chain of custody of that house.
But I'm renting it and it was weird for me.
It was like a whole process for me to go back.
In David Choe's fashion,
I'm gonna reveal something of myself
in this David Choe review.
I felt weird about it.
Like I didn't want to live there.
And yeah, it's a nice place, was always a nice place.
There's good memories there,
there's less good memories there.
There's bad memories there.
And, but you know, we need more space
and like looking at the real estate market
and me being the escapist that I am
and investing in real estate
it's just like terrifying for me.
(laughs)
And so this opportunity came up,
the renters had moved out
and my folks offered it to us.
I knew April wanted to be there,
it's great for Zuma, but for me,
I wasn't super into it.
And like, I didn't really wanna live there.
Even after we moved in,
it still doesn't feel like me.
But to see what he did to his,
I'm not about to like start painting the walls
in David Choe fashion.
I mean he just turns the whole house into an art studio.
It's like paint everywhere.
It's bizarre.
Clay.
I couldn't like think straight in a place like that,
but it just gave me permission own my situation,
if that makes sense.
So early on in the episode that I watched,
which was episode two with Will Arnett and Denzel Curry,
this really brilliant young musician.
I just thought it really kind of gave me permission
to own where I'm at, in a way.
And I didn't expect that from a talk show.
So, you know, when you go that deep,
I have such respect for it and it works.
It's not just like going deep to try to be cool.
No.
It's like authentic,
it works.
It's so authentic.
And I think there's a method to the madness
that plays into why he's in that house.
And the very strange manner in which the show unfolds,
because it's nothing, if not, you know, anarchy and chaos,
but he's so vulnerable and he's so creative
and he's so original that you're riveted by it.
And so these episodes essentially work like triptychs like,
they're a couple, usually three, interviews
that you toggle back and forth between.
He's talking to interesting people while he's also painting
their portrait and doing strange role play.
Like I watched two of the episodes, three.
We should say it's streaming on FX.
There's only four episodes.
I watched episode three and four,
three is with Rainn Wilson, my friend,
Neil Strauss and Erica Garza episode four has Steve-O
and Maya Erskine in it and Van Kilmer pops up.
I mean, Val Kilmer is like, it's insane this guy.
But I can't even describe this show because,
like in Bo Burnham's inside,
it doesn't match up to anything that we're familiar with.
But Bo's show is even more accessible in a way.
It's a little more straightforward.
It's not like, you go from one guest to the next.
Imagine David Choe covered in head to toe in paint
and throwing paint on the wall
and covering his face in clay.
And then extrapolate that into this show,
that's a pastiche of interview meets art project
meets performance art with animations
and archival footage of him as a kid.
And great use of extras, dancers.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
But truly what it is,
is an excavation of his psyche and a process for him
to heal his emotional childhood trauma,
which I think is part and parcel
of why he lives in his childhood house.
Like he's a prisoner of certain loops
that play out in his head that become manifest
and you can see him struggling with how to overcome them.
And so many of his conversations are about, you know,
processing that in real time in conversation with people
who have analogous childhood trauma experiences.
And his childhood trauma,
well, he has two that he talked about in episode two.
That was, one, is when he was four years old,
he was sent away to Korea.
Right.
Ripped away, kike his parents shipped him off
because they needed to get rid of one kid
because they had a financial problem, I think
and they had to like move in with a family members,
but they didn't want three kids.
And so they chose him because I think he thought
he was the odd ball and that just messed with them.
Imagine being four years old and being sent away,
it's like, I can't even imagine that.
And then while he was over there,
he suspects, he doesn't have clear memories of it,
but suspects sexual abuse in Korea, I believe so.
Where I live now is where my childhood trauma happens.
So that's what I mean by permission,
it's like a deeper recognition.
Also an opportunity.
Like there's a reason why you're back in this house.
You have an opportunity to not just revisit that past,
but work through it so that you can develop a new
and healthier relationship with your past
and with this domicile.
I think it's a gift in certain ways
that might feel uncomfortable right now.
But I think the show shows you a guy struggling
in real time with just how to do that.
It's amazing.
It's amazing that that's like the key,
I just didn't expect.
You gotta make it your own though.
You gotta work.
You gotta do the day-to-day stuff.
And he does do the work.
He's a deep man.
He guides them on a guided meditation.
There's nothing I want more right now
than the David Choe guided meditation.
(laughs)
I think what draws me to him
is that, it's one thing to say he's he's vulnerable,
but he has such a big heart.
Like he leads with his heart, it's right on the surface.
Like he wants to connect with other people
so profoundly and you can see his struggle
and that's very appealing.
Like there's a humanity to that guy
that is really irresistible and utterly fascinating.
And at the same time, he lives his life.
Yes, he's got a lot of money, but that aside,
like he allows himself to be so free and childlike.
And his art is all about trying,
like doing everything that he can to make sure that,
that doesn't get calcified.
It's so physical, his art
it's incredibly physical
and he's not the only artist that's like that.
There's a lot of really physical,
but he is exceptionally physical
and it's all about losing trauma.
I mean, when you watch episode two,
what he and Denzel Curry create together, is magical.
Like I didn't even heard of Denzel Curry before,
and he's really special.
I can't wait to listen to more of his music
and a really special guy.
I have to see that.
I had to wash the other ones first,
'cause I'm friends with Neil Strauss
who always gives unbelievable advice and feedback
on matters emotional and psychological,
especially with respect to overcoming trauma.
And Steve-O, who doesn't love Steve-O?
And David goes right to the heart with Steve-O
and gets just gold out of that guy,
while he's like painting.
What he does is he paints these
portraits and then in the middle of that,
they're sort of participatory like,
the subject is participating in how the portrait unfolds.
And I know that's a big part of the Curry thing.
Yes, 'cause they actually..
Where you paint it you destroy it,
you reconfigure it, you re-imagine it.
And it has like nine lives before it's complete.
And it's cool to see that kind of unfold as a result of
and a reflection of the conversation that they just had.
I would say, it's not for everybody.
I could definitely see some people being turned off
by the nature of it, the jagged nature,
the chaotic nature.
You know, I will say that say that.
I'm not saying don't watch it 'cause I think it's great,
but I could see people being.
It's all avant garde let's put it that way.
Yeah, but you know,
get over yourself and check it out,
that's what I say.
You're avant-garde, right?
Final thing that I wanna do really quickly
here is to shout out Chris Nee
and her new show, We the People.
She's created this children's show
that was produced by,
I believe the Obama's' production company.
It features people like Amanda Gordon.
And it's kind of like a really upgraded version
of schoolhouse rock in many ways.
Chris, if you're listening,
thank you for creating this beautiful thing.
I believe Chris listens to the podcast
and I just wanted to acknowledge her and this amazing work.
There's a great profile of her in the New York times
and I'll link that up in the show notes.
So if you've got kids and you're looking for something
edifying for your child, check out, We, the People.
Check it out, I have not seen it yet, congrats Chris.
On the kid note,
we watch a lot of Bluey at our house.
I don't know if anybody with kids that knows Bluey.
I miss those kid days and yet I'm so happy
I'm not there anymore.
But you know what?
As great a work of art as Choe's show and Bo Burnham is,
Bluey is a juggernaut.
Bluey is one of the best animated shows of all time.
It's amassed to half a billion views.
It is considered one of the best shows on television now.
And it comes from Queensland Australia.
It's the biggest show in the history
of the Australian broadcasting company.
The creator is Joe Brumm.
And he is like kind of this dad
that geeks out on play and learns about play.
And that's what's so beautiful about this.
It's a family of four, you've got an older girl named Bluey,
the younger girl, about four years old.
So like a six year old and a four year old,
four year old named Bingo, and then you have the dad.
The dad, his name is Bandit,
I'm spacing on the mom's name.
And bandit is arguably the best,
The Guardian calls him,
arguably the best screen dad of all time, comes up
with the most amazing games.
And so like dad goals wise, Bandit is the man.
But what's great about it is it's hilarious
and it's beautiful and it's fun.
And anyone of all ages could watch it,
my four year old nephew turned me on to it.
Zuma's too young to even enjoy it,
but April and I watch it ourselves (laughs)
'cause it's that good.
And these days, Hollywood a-listers are gunning
to be for in guest roles for season three.
And I think it just shows you or what I'm getting out of it
is how much play can do, not just for the kids,
but for the grownups and kind of that space
it opens up in your brain.
It's so realistic, even though
it's just these four dogs and it's very touching.
So that has been high on my list.
But I also watched last night,
the first episode of the 100 foot wave.
You heard of this documentary series on HBO?
It's the Nazare doc.
The Nazare, yeah.
And episode one is a great history
of big wave surfing, including the, the tow in.
An intervention that Laird and his crew was a part of.
It's mostly focused though on Garrett McNamara,
who by that time, was a kind of 35 year old pro surfer
that had opened up a shop because he needed to make money
and he had kids.
He never really wanted to be the shop owner.
The shop was doing fine,
but he didn't really love that life.
And then all of a sudden he's on the beach
when Laird and his guys are out on a Zodiac
getting pulled into the mountains
beyond the regular surf break.
And it just opened up his whole mind and possibility.
And Garrett McNamara is the first guy
to get barreled at jaws.
And he was approached about,
and it's something that in my Maya Gabeira story
that I got into.
Just a local guy in his Nazare,
sent him an email and started to say,
"Hey you gotta come surf these waves."
So he was like the first guy to surf that wave.
Not just the first guy to surf it,
but he built the entire infrastructure
of how to surf it.
So he went over there he studied the wave
with hydraulic whoever, hydro whatever,
the engineers that understand how the wave
was made, he studied it with academics.
He then went to the local kind of motorcycle dealer
and figured out a way to get jet skis
and get funding for the jet skis.
He taught local people how to ride the jet skis
and how to be safety people.
He found other surfers to come in, including Andrew Cotton,
who was a plumber in Devin,
a young plumber in Devin,
but also was riding big waves in Ireland with his buddy.
And none of his Hawaiian friends would come over.
He invited everyone, all the big names.
None of them would come over.
None of them believed him.
And so he called these two guys he'd never met.
They did a Skype call,
invited them over and together surf this wave,
at its biggest,
and eventually he sets the record and that'll be part
of this documentary and then I'll go forward from there,
but eventually set the world record there at 78 feet,
which is why he was on CNN.
Is that still the record?
No, the record has it's like,
I think someone finally did get the a hundred foot wave
last year, last winter,
but I'm not a 100% sure on that, don't quote me.
But I think there's an argument
that someone maybe eclipsed it.
But it just gets into how he built the entire
infrastructure, his intensity, his greatness
as an athlete and as a leader.
Which I was able to interview him
for the Maya story.
So I knew a little bit about that,
but I wasn't really fully prepared to see it.
And part of the reason it's more impactful
when you see that, is 'cause
there's so much archival footage.
Again, incredible archival footage of him
from way back with him and his family
and how they put this whole thing together in Nazare.
So that's just episode one,
Phillip Glass does the score.
Wow.
The photography's insane.
Who produced this?
And where is it available?
It's on HBO.
So it's HBO Max.
How many episodes is it gonna be?
I don't know how many episodes.
I should study up more before I get here.
HBO likes to drip these things out.
I prefer the Netflix model.
Just put it all out at the same time, you know,
and let people binge it.
I have had some emails with Garrett over the years
about getting them on the podcast.
So that's renewed my enthusiasm
for learning more about this.
He's such a great interview
and he loves to talk about this.
What's amazing is what he told me that's quoted
in the New York times piece was,
you know, no one believed him and he's like, why not?
Like Mavericks get 60, 80 feet,
once every few years, you know.
You might get 60 foot waves, you get 60 foot waves
in Hawaii not all the time, but it does happen,
but it's not very common.
And here in Nazare it's like 60 to 80 feet,
30, 40 times a year.
Why do you think no one believed him?
Well it's different.
It's not a reef break it's a beach break.
It doesn't have the traditional thing where
you know where it's gonna break,
you know where the channel is.
That's part of what's interesting in this first episode
is coming to terms with the fact that it's a beach break,
so the break moves.
And so there's not really one safe area and safe zone.
And it's a different shape than a lot of these waves.
And so I think that was some criticism.
Like, it didn't seem like the typical barrel
and there was just a lot of excuses,
but Garrett was always like, no, no, no.
It's always been like the epic ride.
Well, I'm definitely gonna check that out.
Yeah.
I think that concludes our summer screener list.
That was a good one.
What do you think?
You did have a parting shot though.
My parting shot?
Yes.
Oh yes, is there too much content, Bo?
Can there be too much content?
I think the better question is,
will there ever be a mono culture again.
Like we grew up in an era where there are huge hits
and whether it was a movie or a TV show or an album
that came out, that everyone would talk about
at the same time.
And I think with few exceptions, that's a bygone era.
And I think the trend is gonna be more content
and more specialization, and that makes it less likely
that we're gonna have a shared experience
in terms of, you know, entertainment, books,
movies, television, music.
I think, and even the bigger question is,
is that a good thing or a bad thing?
Or is it just a thing?
It is definitely a thing.
I don't know if it's just a thing.
Until ultimately every single person
will just have their own unique silo
and we'll be living in 10 billion different silos.
And we'll only be watching our own silo.
We'll be watching ourselves like Bo Burnham
locked in his house and inside.
How's it going this week?
Well, I had one view and one download.
I was my own view.
I got five stars.
Or everybody watches everybody else's thing one time.
So everybody gets one view,
but that one view isn't you.
I don't know how that works.
Welcome to the internet.
Yes, we're all living in our own private Truman show,
self-aware yet unable to escape.
♪ Could I interest you in everything all of the time? ♪
♪ A little bit of everything all of the time. ♪
All right, we're like two hours into this
and we have a long way.
Oh, awesome.
Wait, is that good?
I don't know.
I'm gonna feel like Bo in the end.
Or it just is.
It just is.
I don't think we started at 12 though.
I don't know, did we?
Well, let's pivot.
We got a few wins of the week.
We can rifle through these pretty quickly,
but we've got to get through them because
I can't do a podcast and not talk about this stuff.
First up, of course, yesterday,
the Tour de France concluded Adam,
I know your allegiance to free diving,
so I'm not sure if you're aware of this bike race
that was happening over the course of last month.
I used to love that the Phil Liggett commentary
on the old Tour de France.
I've got a good Phil Liggett story.
Oh, really?
First of all.
Is he still around?
Yeah, Phil Liggett is around.
I mean, Paul Sherwin died.
I think he died, I can't remember how many years ago.
I think he had cancer.
But they used to do it together.
And them together, I mean, all time.
They're like the greatest.
Remember the John Tesh, Phil Liggett stuff on like,
** sports?
I think they covered it.
I don't remember that,
but there is nobody like Phill Liggett,
who can keep you occupied
and fixated for six hours straight
while cyclists are riding through cornfields,
past old fortresses and castles,
and just regale you with endless stories.
And I mean, it is an unbelievable talent.
He is the goat.
But several years ago, we were at the tour of California.
I took the boys to the tour of California,
Tyler and Trapper.
We joined my friend, John Moffitt,
and I'm friendly with Craig Hummer
who was doing commentary at the time.
And Paul and Phil were in the booth,
We were in Solvang, it was the time trial
of the tour of California.
And Craig Hummer came out and then Paul Sherwin came out
and Trapper, who's really great with voices
and impersonations, does an unbelievable,
Phill Ligget impersonation.
So I was like, Trapper, you gotta do your Phill for Paul.
So he did it, and Paul was like, come with me.
And he takes us into the booth.
And Paul Sherwin's like, "Phill, Phill, you gotta hear this.
"You gotta hear this."
I mean, Trapper was like 14, 16, or something like that,
and Trapper goes into a full Phill Liggett routine for him
and he was just delighted.
That's amazing.
It's such a highlight.
We were talking about it last night
at dinner as a matter of fact.
Anyway, do you know who won the Tour de France?
I know he was Slovenian.
I'm talking about the Tour de France,
not the Tour de France the Tour de France.
The original Tour de France.
Not le tour.
I'm talking about the Alt Tour.
I can't, something Morton.
Lachlan Morton
Lachlan Morton.
Lachlan Morton this is an unbelievable story.
I'm working really hard to get Lachlan on the podcast
'cause I got to know more about this.
For those that don't know,
Lachlan Morton is a professional cyclist
on the EF Education NIPPO team.
He was not picked to be on the tour de France team.
And this guy being no stranger to all manner of crazy
ultra endurance challenges, he held the EverSting record,
at one point, he's done all kinds of cool stuff.
Decided that he wanted to ride the entire Tour de France
course solo and unsupported
in this beautiful nostalgic throwback
to the spirit of the original Tour de France,
which started in 1903.
When it really wasn't a professional affair,
it was really devised to sell newspapers and was populated
by cyclists who were kind of like blue collar guys
who were just out there hustling to do something hard
and make a little prize money.
So he goes off and rides 3,424 miles by himself.
Not only does he ride every stage of the Tour de France,
he rides all the transitions in between.
And for a lot of these stages,
there's like hundreds of miles in between where they finish
and where they start the following day.
So 3400 miles, 215,000 feet of climbing the entire route,
plus the transitions.
And he beats the Tour de France to Paris by several days.
So the tour ended on Sunday,
I think he got there like Tuesday morning
or something like that, which is unbelievable.
18 days, 220 hours on the bike.
18 Days, 33,424 miles.
Right.
So what is that?
That's like almost 200 a day, almost.
Yeah, at least.
I mean his final day he rode 340
'cause he was in the south of France
and had to get all the way to Paris.
Yeah, it's almost 200 a day.
And he does it.
I love this guy.
He was having problems with his knee
and the cycling shoes.
So he customized these Birkenstocks,
he modified them so that it would alleviate
the pain in his knee
and I think also to avoid some like trench foot issues.
So he literally rides the whole thing in Birkenstocks
So clip in birks.
And he's sleeping in a sleeping bag on the side of the road.
And he stopping at cafes to eat he's patching
his own flats and being his own mechanic.
And along the way, raises $660,000 for world bicycle relief,
which purchased 4,000 bikes distributed
to those challenged to increase access to education.
So there's a beautiful like service element to all this.
Which does show you how expensive bikes are these days.
Yeah, I don't know what model of bike.
I read it somewhere the model of bike.
But they basically distribute them to like kids
who can't afford them,
who are in impoverished areas where they can't get to school
and stuff like that.
I mean, this was like an internet phenomenon first of all.
Bigger than the tour on the internet.
People were losing their minds yeah.
EF, the team, reported, I mean, look,
the Tour de France is on NBC every day,
so that's reaching a ridiculous amount of people.
But in terms of EF zone, social media feeds,
they reported that their social media posts
that involve what Lachlan was doing,
outperformed posts that they were sharing
from the actual Tour de France
by a vector of two to one, which is fascinating.
So the question becomes,
what can we learn from this?
Well, Jason Gay at The Wall Street Journal
has some thoughts on that.
The wall street journal and Jason covered this extensively.
I think he wrote three articles about this,
but he essentially says like, this is a model
for how a modern sports operation
can widen its ambitions and grow its audience.
This idea of this authentic homespun adventure
that is accessible to people that they can follow online,
that they feel an emotional connection with.
And kind of in an aspirational sense,
feel like, perhaps they could do one day as well.
Like nobody's gonna be able
to hammer the individual time trial
at the Tour de France at 40 miles an hour.
But the idea of just getting on your bike
with a sleeping bag and riding around France
until you finish is aspirational enough,
that I think it really engender that kind of grassroots.
It's the iron cowboy effect.
Digital support.
It's the same idea.
Same idea.
In one case, the Tour and the professional people
associated with it are promoting it and want it to happen
and the other one, the Ironman and people are like,
pretending it's not happening.
Well maybe it would be different if you could sign up
for the Tour de France, if you just paid enough money.
You know what I mean, that's the difference.
Iron man, they didn't want to cannibalize their brand.
I think there was shortsighted in that regard,
it's a little bit different here,
but I think the point being,
and this is the point that Jason Gay is making,
like this should be studied in business schools.
Like every sports organization should understand that these
kind of events are percolating up.
We saw it with the iron cowboy,
we're seeing it with Robbie Ballenger,
we're seeing it with Timothy Olson and all kinds of people
all over the country.
And a lot of this is an emergent out of the pandemic
and races getting canceled, saying,
I'm gonna figure out this thing for myself
and I'm gonna share it transparently as it unfolds
on digital media.
It's sort of like the difference between posting
an image on Instagram,
that's highly edited and filtered and looks perfect
versus an Instagram story, that's just raw
and on the fly and authentic.
And there's something about that rawness
that we're compelled by.
And I think what Lachlan did is extraordinary.
I think far more difficult than people realize.
And just so fucking cool, you know,
to challenge the orthodoxy in this way.
And so when I asked you who won the tour de France,
like Lachlan Morton got there on Tuesday,
those guys got there on Sunday, who won the tour de France?
Lachlan.
Yeah.
So I hope to make it happen to get them on the podcast
I'm working on it 'cause it's just a fascinating story.
On the subject of the tour de France specifically,
do we really need to spend a lot of time here?
I mean, anybody who cares probably watched it on TV,
but I did want to shout out Mark Cavendish,
who at 36 years of age and in the waning days of his career,
won four stages, he tied Eddie Merce's record
with 34 total stage wins, which is unbelievable.
Especially when you consider that, you know,
he basically was in this state where his career
was essentially over.
He hadn't won a stage in five years.
He hadn't won the green Jersey.
This is the second time that he's won the green jersy.
The first time was 10 years ago and he almost hung it up.
He got a one-year contract with this team.
He wasn't gonna go to the tour de France.
He wasn't training to go to the tour de France
and then their lead sprinter, Sam Bennett,
this Irish guy who was last year's green jersey winner
gets injured, can attend.
They elevate Cavendish to go to the tour.
There was zero expectations of this guy, you know,
doing anything significant.
And he ends up winning four stages,
runs away with a green Jersey.
I mean, it's crazy.
And over the past couple of years,
he's dealt with Epstein-Barr Virus.
He's had several crashes.
There's been some depression,
all kinds of stuff that would indicate that
his days of being in top form were in the rear view mirror.
So how can you not love that story?
It's unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
A little bit of drama,
he threw a tantrum a couple of days ago
in front of a bike mechanic.
People lost their minds a little bit on Twitter.
There's a lot of bagging on him,
but listen, man, you don't win the green jersey
a second time and win four stages
unless you're a bit of a perfectionist.
And so he had a little bit of a hot head moment.
Who cares.
Get over it.
He's always been on Instagram.
He's always talking about his teammates
and how much he loves them
and how grateful he is for all their support.
So I think he just had had a moment.
You're allowed to have moments in life.
I mean, we have to allow people
to be not nice sometimes, it's okay.
He regretted it, he apologized.
I think that apology was genuine.
You know these guys are exhausted.
We're not talking about him because he's the nicest guy
in town, we're talking about him because he did
something only Eddy Merck had done before.
Right, exactly
Speaking of doing something only one other person
had ever done before.
My favorite kind of emergent talent
out of the tour is Out Van Aert,
this guy's unbelievable.
26 years old, not a newcomer to the tour de France,
he's been around for a little bit,
but he won a sprint stage.
He almost won a second sprint stage.
He almost out sprinted Cav and another sprint stage.
He almost took him to sprint stages.
But he also won a mountain stage,
a climbing stage where
he broke away from the pack and he won
the individual time trial, which is like unbelievable.
The versatility of this guy.
So he won the final sprint stage on the final day
on the Champs-Elysees beating Cav.
Nobody has won a sprint climbing and time trial stage
since Bernardino in 1979.
So to me, that's super exciting to watch him.
And of course we have Tadej Pogacar are on a second win.
This kid's only 22 years old,
second yellow Jersey from Slovenia.
They make them hard in Slovenia,
I can tell you there's a lot of crazy ultra endurance
athletes, exceptional ultra endurance
athletes from Slovenia.
There's another Slovenian we're going to talk about
in a little bit.
There is isn't there, before we do that.
Yeah, so this guy, yellow jersey, but also the white jersey,
'cause he's the outstanding young rider
and the polka dot jersey winner.
I mean, where does this guy go from here.
To a bigger closet.
He's gotta get one of those Home Depot closet installers.
He needs a bigger closet 'cause the closet space
in Europe is smaller.
Okay, I don't know what you're talking about.
You said where he goes from here.
He's got all these jerseys.
He does, yeah.
I'm sure I'll hang them on his wall or do something.
But unbelievable performance.
He was never really challenged at all
throughout this whole thing.
So he's set up.
A long career.
He set up for potentially a couple more of these.
Legend, legendary status.
I did wanna shout out, the announcers,
like we're unplugged at our house,
so I don't have television.
I don't even know if I have like an NBC streaming.
I don't have a peacock or anything like that.
But when I was in New York City, like I said,
I would go home every night and watch the tour
and went into that thinking,
how exciting is this tour gonna be?
I hadn't really been following a cycling that closely,
but I thought it was a super exciting tour
and I think that the commentators
deserve a lot of credit for that.
Again, Phil Ligget being the goat,
but right next to him, Bob Roll, my namesake.
You know how many times I get discounts?
I go into bike shops.
Really?
When I go into a bike shop and I need to buy something,
invariably, they're like, are you related to Bob Roll?
And you say, yes.
I say yes, and I get a discount.
(laughs)
Paul Burmeister, who I was not familiar with,
but also Christian Vanderbilt, shout out to Christian.
Those guys did an unbelievable job.
So thank you for riveting me.
What else we got to talk about?
Well, we have Hardrock 100.
Yes.
Hardrock 100, a hundred miles.
We're turning into an endurance report card here
with everything that's going on.
But yeah, Hardrock 100 was this past weekend.
This race, I can't wrap my head around how difficult
this race must be.
It's a hundred mile foot race with 30,000 feet
of elevation gain at 11,000 feet of altitude.
And they haven't run this race in the past couple of years.
In 2019, there was snow and some risk of avalanche,
so they canceled it.
In 2020, of course COVID and it ended that from happening.
So it hasn't happened in a little while,
but it was a pretty exciting race this year.
The top three men all broke the previous counterclockwise
record of 23 hours and 28 minutes
set by Kilian Jornet in 2015.
In first place this guy Francoise D'Haene finished
in 21 hours and 45 minutes, which is the fastest time ever.
I guess the clockwise version of the race they alternate
year by year is a little bit easier.
And Kilian had that record at 2241.
It's a huge accomplishment when anyone
runs a hundred miles in under 24 hours
and these guys are getting 33,000 feet of elevation gain,
and this guy does it in 21 hours and 45 minutes.
Like it just bends my mind.
And second place went to Dylan Bowman podcaster,
podcast fan, I think, what's up Dylan?
22 hours and 45 minutes.
He'd never done that race before.
So that's a huge accomplishment for Dylan
and super cool to see.
Unfortunately, Courtney Dauwalter,
that podcast is going up August 2nd, I think,
we recorded it a while ago.
Hardrock was one of two races that Courtney
was really keying in on for this year.
She was running in fourth place overall,
so Dylan Bowman, Ryan Smith and Francoise
were the only ones ahead of her.
But started having stomach issues
and at 62 miles, she dropped out.
So that's a bummer for her.
So I hated to see that.
You can't eat or drink
You're done.
I think stomach issues turned into some
other kinds of issues and it was just the right thing
to pull out.
She's running UTMB in August,
so back to the drawing board and hopefully she's healthy
and figures all that stuff out
so that she can crush it there.
But the woman who won, this woman,
Sabrina Stanley she's the returning champ,
did it in 27 hours and 21 minutes.
Like it's just mind bending to me,
like at this kind of altitude and this kind of elevation
gain that these people can run that fast.
So anyway, that's that.
That's cool, I wanted to update everybody
on Jason Caldwell, we talked several weeks ago
about the great Pacific race.
Jason and his teammates, Angus Collins,
Gus Barton and Dunkin Roy who were attempting to break
the record for, how do you call it?
Like, the fastest ever to row from San Francisco to Hawaii,
which I guess is the Guinness record
for human powered crossing of the mid Pacific.
They completed it.
It's 2,400 nautical miles.
Only 50 have attempted this.
They met all kinds of weather and huge swells
and all that kind of stuff, but they broke the record
by nine days, which is insane.
Unbelievable, I was following that story with you
and I mean, that's just incredible, nine day.
Yeah.
Record shatter.
How long were they out there?
Let's see, they started May the 31st then they finished.
What day did they finish?
I don't know the cumulative time.
They've been done for a little while.
So, it was like 28 days or something like that.
I saw an interview with Jason and he was saying that
the big challenge immediately was that they can't walk.
Like literally, other than walking
from one end of the boat to the other,
they haven't walked in in a month.
Jelly legs.
They'll have to figure out
how to walk and there's some kind of weird atrophy
and all the weight loss that they experience.
Is that right?
Yeah.
They're like just torsos on twig legs.
(laughs)
I don't know.
But rowing requires a lot of leg strength too.
So I don't know how that works.
So maybe different types of muscles.
We can get them like one of those sit-down bicycles,
they can get around that way.
A recumbent.
Yeah the recumbent bicycle.
I can see you on a recumbent.
No you can't.
Going up and down PCH.
Grow some kind of weird beard and the little
you know, rear view mirror.
If this experiment, renting, the family house goes awry,
I could escape on a recumbent.
The recumbent bicycle is a close cousin
to the snorkel mask.
It's the cycling version of swimming snorkel mask.
(laughs)
Not in my world by friend.
So like cyclists look at recumbent cyclists,
the way swimmers look at people that were snorkel mask.
Maybe that's help You understand where I'm coming from.
I'm bringing the mask that Choe's house.
I didn't plan that, it came back very organically.
Good job.
I'm glad it's back.
The audience demands it.
Speaking of my swim mask,
there's been a free diving competition going on.
Vertical blue, which is.
We couldn't get through this podcast
without a free diving update.
Listen, Vertical Blue is the Tour de France
of free diving baby.
It takes place in Long Island Bahamas at a place called
Dean's blue hole,
which is just off the beach.
Steps off the beach there's a sink hole,
like a limestone hole that goes down to 202 meters.
So 630, 660 feet.
Right.
Whatever that is.
And they drop a line, William Trubridge,
one of the best in the history of the sport, lives there
discovered the place as a free diving destination,
created the infrastructure for it much in the same way
that Garrett did for Nazare, Will did for free diving.
And what's beautiful about it is there's no current.
So like conditions are always good.
I mean, sometimes if visibility is better than others
and it's always nicer to have some vis.
But really when they're going deep, it doesn't matter
that much only matters for the pictures.
And this year is seeing some of the most incredible records.
I can't remember seeing this many records,
so I'm gonna have to put on my phone,
so I don't miss anyone because
it's a big deal and everyone needs the recognition.
But let's start with Alexey Molchanov
who we've talked about before.
He's the record holder for two of the three disciplines
on the men's side, the constant weight record,
which is a monofin basically.
They call it constant weight because
anytime you do competitive free diving,
whatever weight you swim down with,
you have to bring up with you.
So it really all the dives are constant weight.
It's just a bad name for it.
I should it be called the monofin.
There's no event where you're carrying some big weight,
and then when you get to the bottom, you drop it again
and come back up.
That used to be the way.
So in the early days, like in big blue, you know,
the early days of free diving,
they were competing in variable weight,
which is that you could take a weighted sled down
and then swim back up.
Now it's all swim down, swim up.
And so, he broke his constant record,
which was 130 meters, he got to 131 meters.
But more impressive than that in certain ways,
it was his free immersion dive.
Which is you pull down along the line, free fall
to the bottom, get your tag, and you pull a line,
not wearing any fins at all,
you pull line all the way back to the surface.
He did that to 126 meters.
And the dive was four minutes and 45 seconds.
And it looked like he'd walked around the block.
I mean, obviously it was incredible,
but to be underwater and doing that kind of physical
activity that long, it's just remarkable this guy.
Four minutes and 45 seconds.
For minutes, 45 seconds.
This guy is doing things that we just haven't seen before.
You know, he's broken the record on bi-fins, dynamic,
he's broken the record in ice and he's doing it all.
The only thing he doesn't have is the constant
no fins record, which is still Wills.
I think it's 102 meters.
And that's on the men's side, but Alenka Artnik,
which we've also talked about her, she's a Slovenian.
And when I was covering the sport for one breath,
Alexi's record was still at 128 meters.
So it was still close.
Alexi's mom, Natalia Mulchanova,
the most decorated in the history of the sport
had the constant weight record on the women's side
at 101 meters.
Now the thought was she could have gone much deeper
than that, she just didn't have to.
and that's been Alexi's philosophy too,
why should I put the effort out to break the record,
just to push it a meter when no one's threatening it.
But you know, lately Alenka Artnek and Alessia Zecchini
an Italian have been pushing each other.
And the beginning of this, you know,
I wrote about a Alenka when she got to 114 meters
in the red sea earlier this year.
Alessia Zecchini was in Italy during lockdown.
She couldn't go anywhere.
She couldn't train in anything,
but like a 60 meter pool that Italy has.
Finally when they opened up and she's watching Alenka
do amazing things.
Well on day one of vertical blue,
she hit 115 meters and broke the record.
It was at 114 before that.
So she broke it by a meter.
And she held it for about 10 minutes.
And Alenka got in right after hit 218,
and then just the other day,
two days later, got to 120 meters.
So she continues to advance, to levels.
Those are huge gains.
It's huge numbers.
I look at Alenka as potentially the biggest threat
to Alexi's overall record.
Just because she's showing...
She's improving at that rate,
she could get to 131.
'Cause she has the capacity to equalize
and she's coming up without threat of blackout.
So she's got something down, some relaxation,
some power, unbelievable athlete.
Today, Alessia was set to dive to 118 meters.
So I think she's still trying to go for it.
Meanwhile, Alessia also broke the no fins record
on the women's side at the same competition,
74 meters without any fins.
And she did that as an attribute to the person who
held it before, which is Sayuri Kinoshita,
who died very young in a freak,
not a diving accident at all,
just a freak accident in her home, in Japan.
And so Alessia kind of gave that shout out
on her social media.
So we'll link to all the social media accounts
that we're mentioning here.
Two other records to note, one is bi-fins record
for men, Arnaud, I'm gonna space on his last name.
Arnaud has got to a hundred and 116 meters
with by fins and another French woman
who I had not kept track of before she broke
the women's side on bi-fins.
And so the, we'll link to all of these accounts
to make sure that.
We have Alenka's Instagram up here,
it looks like it's like a five minute video.
Did you want to show us a little bit of that?
Yeah let's look at it this is what the Dean's blue hole
with a monofin dive looks like.
And you'll see her at the beginning kind of breathing
up on the surface.
So for people that are listening and not watching,
what's the Instagram account, it's @Alenka_ I think.
Yeah, what is it?
Let's see, it is @Alenka_artnik A R T N I K.
Sorry, we should have had this playing this entire time.
Right so there she is, she's going down.
I mean, we're not gonna watch all five minutes of this.
No, but if you fast forward just a little bit,
you could see, and she goes deeper and deeper and deeper.
So there's no line here.
I don't see a line.
There is a line.
Oh, there it is.
She's just passing the sand falls.
So as you go down in this limestone hole,
sand continues to pour off these cliffs
and it looks like the photo negative of a waterfall.
To be in this place It's magic.
I mean, look at that, and look at her elegant
kind of movement.
So 120 there is showing the depth.
No, the depth is here.
Oh, the 40 are there.
And then there, you have the second.
So, you know, the idea is to go a little faster
than a meter.
120 is the record, yeah.
120 is the record.
Well, that's what she's going for.
Arnaud Jerald is the bi-fin's record on the men's side.
And he got to 116 meters.
And Alexi has told me he's maybe going
for the bisons record also.
So Arnaud has to watch his back there.
Wait, she hit it, let's see where she eclipses
the record there.
She gets all the way down.
So in order to get the record,
it's not just getting to the bottom.
you have to make it all the way back to the top unassisted
and then you have to demonstrate to the judges
that you're still lucid.
You can't black out.
If you black out you're disqualified.
So, it basically it dicentivizes you
from pushing too hard.
Yeah 'cause if you don't make it through unscathed,
it doesn't count.
On the women's side. Alice Madolo,
who's a dentist in France.
And she did the women's bi-fins record to 95 meters.
'Cause if you're looking at this,
it does help to have the monofin,
it's much bigger, much wider
and when you do the dolphin kick,
you're just pushing so much more water.
She has a pretty wide kick.
I mean, there's different types of monofin
also that that vary in their flexibility.
But the key is, they can expend
a lot of energy because they're relying on your thighs
and your core to propel you.
So if you really, you know, put your energy into it,
you can deplete yourself very quickly.
But if you have a very malleable fin
and you have a very slow, graceful,
methodical kick to it, you can move.
And this is what they're perfect at,
of moving expeditiously without oxygen expenditure.
Well yes, but I mean,
remember she's been under water for two minutes already,
or like almost two minutes,
and then she has to start kicking all the way back.
And you know, you've been holding your breath that long,
and now you have to sprint basically.
And you know, without taking a breath.
She's breaking the surface here.
It's been three minutes and 20 seconds.
28, I think.
She has to flash the sign,
take everything off her face and say I'm okay.
You have to demonstrate like motor acuity, right?
Like if you be able to take your stuff off and show, right.
You have to clear your face of all equipment
flash the okay sign and say I'm okay.
People ever do that and then blackout?
If they don't, then they have to hold
it for like 10 seconds.
That's why there was a delay there
before the judge gave it to him.
The judge wants to know they're not gonna do that.
Usually by the time you were to do this
and you're like, I'm okay,
that's when you're gonna black out by then.
Wow, it's cool, man.
Awesome.
That's it.
All right, vertical blue update complete.
I think this has been an endurance roundup
like no other.
We had a whole thing we were gonna talk about the Olympics,
but we're at like over two and a half hours here.
Let's get to the listener questions.
Then we can table the Olympics for next time,
because there's gonna be a lot
of Olympic stuff to talk about in the weeks to come.
The listener questions, Jason has them downloaded.
First up we have Eric from South bend.
Excellent.
Yeah.
You are a very good reader.
Thank you, and when you say such nice things to me,
your odds really shoot up about being played on the air.
Oh, is that what it is?
Adam is the one selecting these things.
I didn't even see that until just now.
No it's cool you deserve it man.
Thank you.
That's a great question.
Do you wanna go first?
I feel like on some level he's speaking
to you because you have young kids
and I can chime in.
Okay.
But maybe you want to lead out here.
Well I guess my lead would be,
I think it works you know, it takes communication
and in a writeup, before Iron cowboy,
when it was even a discussion or a possibility,
we were talking about it.
And then as it approached and we picked our dates,
there was still discussion of it.
In the end, we found a way to make it work for all of us.
So when it came to our trip,
we actually got April and Zuma in with the grandparents
and situated, so she had support
and backup for that specific trip.
But in general, in terms of getting back
to what we're more used to,
like when I'm home working,
I still have my chunks of time with him.
So I do the breakfast I do then I work.
I do breakfast and play with them in the morning
then I do work all day.
Sometimes I'll do a run with him in the stroller
or in the afternoon.
And I'm in charge of kind of late afternoon into dinner
and bath time and that kind of stuff.
So we chunk the day out.
And if I'm in town working, I can plug into those chunks.
Like when I'm here at the studio
and I don't get back until after five
or close to five o'clock,
that's more like the nine to five schedule.
Then I'll come in and I'll still manage everything,
before dinner, getting him ready for food,
doing the bath time and transitioning towards bedtime.
I'll do that.
So that doesn't change.
So to me, like the way I look at it is,
how can you chunk out the day,
so that you plug in where you can
so that he still has a hands-on experience with his dad
so that your wife or partner has some sort of dependence
that she's not in it on her own
and how else you can do it.
And the other thing that we're doing
is we're kind of trying to get other childcare going.
So we've been engaging with nanny stuff.
And we have a nanny now that we think is working,
but he's been a pandemic baby.
So he hasn't been super comfortable
with other adults, really.
He loves other kids, but other adults.
Hasn't acclimated to having other people around.
And so we're in the position where we can have
professional childcare,
but it hasn't really been super smooth to implement that.
So we're hoping that that helps because, you know,
April needs a break too,
so we can bring our best to Zuma and Zuma needs
to be comfortable with other human beings
and be confident in different settings.
So, you know, my best advice to you is
I was really hungry to get back out
and reporting in a different way.
And not just because I was like home with a family,
but because the pandemic itself had made me hungry
to get back into the human connection
and not just report from the desk.
So I really had a good experience with it,
it worked out great for all involved.
We didn't miss a beat.
You know, I am parent B.
April does such a great job that it makes my job
a lot easier and so in my house,
she's the lead and I just try to help where I can.
And so that hasn't changed.
So I don't have any specific advice for you
other than, make sure that you chunk out the time
and show up for your period.
Yeah, I think that's good advice.
I think the first thing that I want to say on this is,
and I'm not the first person to say this, certainly,
but this idea of back to normal.
I get where you're coming from,
like this idea that we're headed back into some version
of what we experienced pre pandemic,
but I would encourage you to try to find other phraseology
for that, or to think about it a little bit
differently because no matter what is to come,
I don't think it's accurate to say
that we're going back to normal,
or at least we shouldn't be going back to whatever
that was prior.
And my hope is that, you know,
even if you must return to an office
and a more typical nine to five experience,
I mean, Adam, I think your words are wise,
but you do have an interesting career in that,
you don't go and sit in a cubicle,
an office building all day, it's different.
You have a little bit more domain and control
over how you structure your day.
But, you know, in this particular context, Eric,
that you seize the moment,
the opportunity that you've been given
to take this experience that you've had
over the last 18, however many months,
the lessons that you've learned along the way,
and the tactics that you've kind of honed
throughout the pandemic to reframe your relationship
to work, in the workplace and how you relate to your kids.
So I guess what I'm saying is, what has your experience been
over the last 18 months?
How has that changed or improved
how you relate to your kids?
How has it changed or informed your relationship to work?
And now that things are presumably opening back up,
how can you take that into this next phase?
So that you're not just pivoting back to what happened prior
to the pandemic, but creating something entirely new.
Secondly, you know I don't want to hold myself out
as a parenting expert.
The pandemic has been really hard on our kids.
They're at an age right now where they really
don't want me talking about them on the show.
So I'm not gonna go into specifics other than to say,
it's been really challenging for them,
for us as a family, figuring out.
Julie and I as parents,
trying to figure out how to best support them.
And that being said,
yes, of course, I think a lot of parents
have experienced more present time
with their kids by dent of sheer proximity
if nothing else just being in the house
with your kids all the time.
For me personally, this is unlikely to change
that much because my work life is not gonna change
that drastically other than travel.
But I have been doing my thing the way I was doing it
before, kind of throughout the pandemic period.
But I think what I want to say is that,
when you venture back into the workplace
in a more conventional way.
That, that connection with your kids,
that perhaps you're getting less of all of a sudden,
I want to encourage you to think about it
from a different perspective,
not from a perspective of time span or volume of time spent
and more about the quality of the time
that you do spend with them.
So as you weather this transition
to less total time spent together.
I think it would be advisable to increase
the presence of mind that you bring to the time
that you do spend together.
Because I think how present you are with them
when you're with them is the most important thing.
Can you completely give yourself over to their cares
and their interests when you're with them?
Unclouded by distractions like your phone or distractions
like your to-do list.
You know, how present are you actually
when you're with your kids?
And I think the quality of that interaction is what
you should focus on because you're gonna have less control
over the volume piece of it.
Like when Zuma's playing with the doorstop,
boing, boing, boing.
Listen, when your little kid is like doing something,
you're like.
This is cool.
Yeah, but you could be like,
I have no interest in this, I'm gonna look at my Twitter
while my kid is doing this, I'm with my kid,
but how can you really be present for that experience
and find a way to be compelled or interested in that
when it's happening.
And I think ultimately a lot of parents like sort of wring
their hands and feel guilty about not being
with their kids all the time,
or there's going to be some separation anxiety
when the kid is acclimated to that.
But I think ultimately, you know,
somebody who has older kids,
what's more important is to be a living example in the world
of somebody who is fulfilled and purposeful and you know,
out there, you know, pursuing something aspirational,
whether it's through career or other interests
and to, you know, be a living embodiment of that,
I think is powerful for the child.
It's not really about like,
oh, I spent all day with my kid
than making sure that that time spent is quality
and that the kid is aware, like when you're not there,
you're doing this thing that engenders their respect.
I think that's a really key thing.
Because if you're at home, but you're depressed,
you're spending more time with your kid,
but you're not in a good frame of mind, what's better?
Well going out into the world and coming home fulfilled,
I think, and being available to your kid
for their needs in those moments,
I think is, is really more important.
And I would say also, you know, to extend that a little bit,
and as a parent of kids who are older,
and as trite as this sounds like, time goes crazy fast.
your child changes with such rapidity.
I mean, Zuma is in a phase right now
where I'm sure week to week,
you can gauge those differences.
And thinking more about that, you know,
I think will help you understand the profundity of it,
and that you really do want to be there for all of it
to embrace all of those changes,
when you're with them to not wish
they were that younger version of themselves,
but to meet them where they currently are,
and to do this, we really have to be mindful and present.
And that might be easier when the world is stopped
and harder when it presumes the velocity,
that's more typical.
So it means like amping up or refocusing
or doubling down on those practices.
And I would conclude by just saying,
being proactive with their needs rather than reactive
is important.
Understanding, it's not about, creating amazing experiences.
Like we're gonna go on this crazy wild adventure
than just being there for the mundane.
Like those mundane everyday experiences,
when you really show up in our present,
can be as meaningful and memorable and profound
as you know, the crazy rollercoaster ride
or the trip to Costa Rica or whatever it is.
Right, it sounds like Eric is got a baby
about Zuma's age and that he is really enjoying
the hands-on and is worried about disconnecting
a little bit from that if he has to go
back out of the house for work.
But I would say, just make sure, for me, it's like,
if you're like, okay, if I have to be somewhere
at eight 30 or nine,
I can still do the morning, I can own the morning.
And if you've been used to kind of sharing
all day duties with your partner,
you just have to chunk out the stuff you're gonna own.
And that's what I've had to do from the beginning
'cause I've been working since like the first few weeks.
And working in the house now,
because I've been working in the house,
she can just hand them to me if she needs to,
or I can be there and I can work at night.
But for the most part, I think that advice stands.
And I think your advice stands too,
that means stay present and you know,
it's okay to like fail at being present sometimes too.
So, at least that's what I say to my wife.
(laughs)
All right let's move on.
Moving on.
Zach in West Virginia
Zach, coming in hot with the invite to West Virginia.
I wanna go to West Virginia.
I've been to West Virginia.
Really?
I grew up in Maryland.
I've been at West Virginia many times.
I wanna go adventuring in West Virginia with Zach.
I think that would be well-advised.
Interesting question.
I think there's a lot to unpack here.
I think this is really not about weightlifting
and whether or not you like it or can learn to love it
or what my experience is with it
and really all about Zach and his relationship to Zach
and these body issues.
I'm curious about where that comes from
and what that's all about.
I mean, look, you're six, two, you're 165 pounds.
So yeah, you're a skinny guy.
For health reasons, if you needed to put mass on,
which I'm not sure that you do, then that's one thing,
but this is really all about your self-consciousness
and your insecurity,
because there's a lot of endurance athletes
out there who would kill for that profile.
Like most dudes are trying to lose weight
and get lean to have that power to weight ratio
that you probably have.
And to be quicker.
Exactly, so the pull into the weight room
to put muscle mass on feels like,
you don't enjoy it, but do you not enjoy it
because you actually don't like the physical process
of lifting weights or did you not like it
because you feel like it's counter to who you are
or what you really want to be doing,
which is out there running and swimming and biking
and all of that stuff.
Or do you not like it because
you're not good at it.
Or yeah, because as David Goggins would say,
who cares if you don't like it.
Sometimes it's good to do things you don't like.
It's good to be a beginner at something.
It's good to be a beginner.
And also if you continue to do it or you find a way to make
it more fun by having friends or, you know,
involved or whatever,
you can learn to like something that originally
you didn't like,
especially as you develop some momentum
and you start to see some gains
and stuff like that.
But really, I don't know that this question
is about weightlifting at all.
It's really about your internal self-consciousness
like, why are you self-conscious at this weight?
It's not like you're 120 pounds, like you're skinny,
but what is the genesis of that insecurity?
Like where does that come from?
What is contributing to it?
And how can you get honest with yourself?
You know, how can you excavate that?
Get honest with yourself,
work through it so that you can just be comfortable
with who you are.
I mean, I think that's the real weight room here.
You know, the emotional weight room.
I like that.
You can go into the gym
and goggins it out and put on a bunch of mass.
But let's say you do that,
you still haven't really,
you've then kind of put on a costume to shroud or mask,
whatever that insecurity is, but have you really
dealt with it?
So I would encourage you, like,
I don't know if you're in therapy
or you have some tools to work through this,
but perhaps do some journaling and an inventory
of the things that make you feel insecure
or childhood experiences that anchored
this connection that you have between your weight
or your skinniness and how you see yourself
or how others like interact with you.
Because really the bigger kind of challenge here
is to get comfortable with who you are,
no matter whether you put on mass or not.
So how can you get over the issue?
What drives it?
And I think, you know, a good place to start
with all of this is with a self-love practice.
Like how can you learn to develop a greater capacity
for self acceptance?
So on that note, if you haven't listened to it already,
my podcasts with Kamal Ravikant
could be a good place to start or re listen to that
'cause it was a while ago.
I would suggest picking up his book,
Love Yourself Like Your Life Depends on It.
And I think that might give you some tools
to begin this journey.
The other thing I would question or wonder
is whether there's some childhood trauma here?
Was there some bullying when you were a kid?
Like how can you resolve whatever that is,
And I don't want to project because
I don't know what that experience is
or was, but how can you find
a way to make peace with yourself and that past
or that association that you have between
your body image and how you feel about yourself internally.
Yeah, I mean, I think it's contentment
in who you are and what you have.
It's very easy to compare yourself to other people
it's normal.
And if you're skinnier than most people at six two,
then you might feel that way.
You know, I look at myself and wish my body
was different sometimes.
So I understand that impulse.
What do you think about swimming for upper body building
stuff, as opposed to the gym?
Does that work for everybody?
You know, it sounds like this guy's an ectomorph.
So yeah, he could probably put on some mass doing that,
but if he wants to do it quickly, you know,
the gym is going to be a better avenue.
But since he enjoys swimming,
if he upped his swimming volume,
maybe that would help him do that.
But, you know, look, swimming is an endurance event,
you know, it's an aerobic exercise in and of itself.
So if mass is his big thing,
the gym is the only way to do that.
Or, you know, it sounds like he's got a fast metabolism,
all of this stuff, but I think all of those again,
are distractions from the real issue,
which is, is his emotional relationship with himself.
Yeah, and just being happy.
It sounds like you have a great life.
You do amazing stuff.
You have work, that's satisfying.
You have a great partner.
You live in a beautiful place.
I mean, I'd say just ride, run and swim.
If you don't like the gym rocket.
And if you think you're skinny, turn on
the Tour de France and look at those guys.
He looks like a 12 year old boy.
That's not helping.
Rich that's not helping, Rich stand down.
He probably weighs 120 pounds.
I don't know how much he weighs.
Those guys are like one 140s to 150s.
Easily
Yeah.
And they can be tall too.
And lighter.
Yeah, a lot of them are tall.
You know, I grew up super skinny as well,
and I wish I was still skinnier.
(laughs)
I would like to be 165 pounds right now.
Sweet spot, I think 180 for me.
All right.
Thank you Zach.
Thanks Zach.
Last one, Chris from Rockville, California,
not to be confused with Rockville, Maryland.
Right, I didn't know we had a Rockville,
although I think we've heard from Chris Jones before.
Have we?
I don't know.
No Rocklin.
Rocklin.
Thank you, Chris.
From Rocklin, not Rockville.
I have put some thought into this,
but one thing I didn't ponder or think about
was Adam leading a free diving symposium.
Yes, not as symposium, a mask fitting experience.
Two day, a six hour intensive.
A six hour intensive on the superiority of masks
to pedestrian goggles.
I love it.
So we do do these retreats in Italy,
COVID canceled last year, we're doing one
next May but obviously those are pricey tickets
and they're limited to not very many people.
So how do we create experiences that are more accessible
and affordable to everybody?
COVID obviously put a clamp on any of that manifesting.
But when I was in New York,
I had some good talks meetings about getting the podcast
tour up on its feet.
I don't know exactly what that's gonna look like,
or when that's gonna happen.
It's not gonna be for a little bit,
but for certain, at some point
we're gonna take a podcast on the road
and do a multi-city tour and some mid large size venues,
which will be organized around some other events
over the course of the day or the weekend there,
with a group run or et cetera, things like that.
So we're working on that kind of stuff.
There's possibility that something's gonna go down
in New York City in the fall, I'll keep you posted on that.
Not sure how that's going to pan out quite yet.
I don't have details on that.
In terms of other kind of wellness oriented weekend
type or week-long events,
I can't say there's anything specifically
in the works for that.
I'm always trying to gauge like how my bandwidth
and how much energy and time that I have.
There's some speaking stuff coming up,
some travel coming up, I've got a new book coming out.
So it's hard to always figure out how to allocate that time
and to do it in a way that's sustainable for me
and you know makes sense with everything
else that that that's going on.
So I appreciate the interest.
We'll put some thought into it.
I think it would be cool to do some kind of, you know,
I dunno, wellness sort of retreat type thing
that is not at the price point that the Italy retreat is
and makes it a little bit more accessible.
We had put some thought into that,
you know, basically like two years ago,
doing like a camp sort of situation where a lot of people
could come and it would be more affordable,
but we never got out of the gate on that
because of the pandemic, et cetera.
So we're revisiting all of that
and I'll keep you guys posted.
I appreciate the interest.
It's a lot of work, man.
I know.
And also it takes a tremendous amount of time,
energy and resources.
Most of those things lose money at the same time.
Is that right?
So it's like, all right, podcast tour with the podcast,
with the book, how do all these things fit
and make sense so that I don't burn out
and just become exhausted.
When do you need my writer for the podcast tour?
When do I need to file that?
Soon.
Soon?
What's going in the writer.
If I see any red in the sides of the shoes on my feet,
any red at all in my dress room,
I'm gonna freak the fuck out, okay?
No red, I better not see red.
What else?
I don't know.
Actually, I really liked the color.
I don't mean to offend people who liked the color red,
please don't cancel me for that.
You have had surreptitiously canceled
for not liking red, Adam.
I look forward to your exciting and specific rider,
but the tour will happen at some point.
That's very real.
And I am excited about that,
I think that's gonna be really cool.
I'm gonna put together five to 10 minutes
of a crowd warmup standup for you, just for you.
That is something I look forward to.
All right, we gotta wrap this.
How do you feel, man?
This might've been our longest one.
You know, this is what happens
when we are away from each other too long.
There's a lot to catch up on.
Just too much to catch up on.
It's also boiling hot in here.
'Cause we had turned the air conditioner off.
We're sweating like crazy.
And there's a lot of great athletes doing amazing stuff.
Right.
Very impressive.
Once you crack it, it's like when you plan a wedding,
well, if I invite this person then
I have to invite this person,
I can't talk about these events
and I don't want to leave anyone out.
'Cause so it's true, like so many athletes
are doing so many amazing things
and I want to just share love with all of them.
With the Olympics on deck, it's unbelievable.
What a time to be alive, Rich.
Unbelievable, in the meantime,
until we're back two weeks from now,
follow Adam at Adam Scolnick on Instagram and Twitter.
If you want your question, fielded, leave us a message
at 4-2-4-2-3-5-4-6-2-6.
You could check out links to everything that we talked
about today in the show notes,
which you can find on the episode page richroll.com.
Please don't forget to hit that subscribe button on YouTube,
Apple, and Spotify, or wherever you enjoy this content.
And that's it, man.
I want to thank everybody who helped put on the show today.
Jason Camiolo for audio engineering production, show notes,
interstitial music, all kinds of behind the scenes stuff.
Blake Curtis for videoing and editing today's
show for YouTube.
Jessica Miranda for graphics.
We have Grace and Wilder for portraits here today,
Georgia Whaley for copywriting, DK, David Kahn
for advertiser relationships and theme music by
my boys, Tyler, Trapper and Harry.
Thanks for the love you guys.
See you back here in a couple of days
with another awesome episode.
I hope you enjoyed this hope you enjoyed Daniel whom
and we got a lot more where that came from.
If I smell rosemary,
even the hint of Rosemary in that dressing room,
I don't know what I'm gonna do.
You're fired.
Brogan you're in.
Peace.
Plants.